Hey,
you fuckers,
what's going on?
You I say that with all love,
all love and do respect.
Tom.
I freaks for free.
Gets this episode of the Joe Rogan,
his parents,
but all mine.
How gross is that?
If I treated you like your mind,
I call my people.
It's not your people's too,
but that's because people,
it's called talk.
Tell what it is.
Yeah.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Squarespace is a,
a website making website that we've been super happy with here on the Joe Rogan
experience podcast.
It's a,
it makes it so that a person like you or I,
you know,
your typical knucklehead who's not exactly technologically proficient,
you can make a website super easy and it's integrated with everything iPod or
whether works with Ipod.
You can integrate it with Twitter and Facebook and stuff,
but it works with android phones,
works with windows,
works with Mac,
uh,
all platforms,
which is easy to do.
Now to God.
He used to be such a pain in the ass.
You would look up a website on internet explorer and it'd be all wonky and then
you look at it on safari and it would be perfect or vice versa.
It was a mess.
Coding websites.
It was like a super difficult task.
Just you know,
five,
10 years ago.
I say that as if I'm a coder,
you I know nothing.
I don't even know coding is.
They could be lying to me,
give you a bunch of magicians working behind the scenes with elves and I'm just
like,
well,
you know,
they it and develop this operating system.
Meanwhile,
it's all magic.
Could easily be magic.
It's because it's just as likely that it's magic as it is that a moron like me,
whatever creates something like anything you could download online.
I don't understand that.
That's so outside of my realm of thinking that a boy.
Anyway,
Squarespace is an extremely easy way to build an awesome website.
Everything is integrated free domains and great designs.
Hosting all in one place.
They provide everything you choose from over 20 Badass designs and they have a
new ecommerce product.
It's Galapagos and it's a hope.
That's how you say it.
That's how you spell it.
There's that word,
that word out loud.
You know there's a free words that like you,
you read and then he'd get to them and you're like,
hmm.
How do you say wall?
La V.
O.
I.
L.
A.
Y is that wall law is at La La.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
written probably better.
Meanwhile,
most people would have no idea how to spell that name.
That word while.
Ah,
that's one that you could get over on people.
I get a spelling contest and then I'd be like,
Ooh,
good.
Everything.
Is it w it sounds like there's a w.
Yeah.
What is it?
Language.
French.
Those fucks.
They don't,
they don't agree.
They don't agree on how the war,
the use of words should sound Savio I l a.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
That's a boiler.
That's not wall La.
It's Voya.
What do you guys doing?
Why are we playing games?
Why do you have to use the same goddamn letters but make them sound different?
Is it French or something?
Yeah,
French like Portuguese is interesting.
Like the,
you just get used to the ar thing and it's pretty recognizable.
But like with Brazilians like hoists Gracie and Hixon Gracie,
those are ours and everybody was like why is it age?
Cause that's how they do it.
There's just as many of them.
Is there a bus?
You know South America is fucking gigantic.
It's a lot of God damn people down there.
You know,
if they say it's an h fucking learn it,
deal with it.
This has nothing to do with squarespace.com which is an awesome product.
Does Galapagos is a new template which will showcase your ecommerce products in
a more interesting way than the typical orderly grid.
And a Galapagos features a dynamic product mosaic with a custom rollover states
so he can roll over and allows you to display an alternate image.
So like if you're looking at a,
an item and then you roll over it with a cursor,
it will allow you to display an alternate image.
Like you can do one in color and one in black and white or something like that.
If you're one of those crafts,
he artsy fucks.
So when visitors hover over each item,
it gives you a different look and the template is also preset.
With all the content pages you need to have your shop on up and running quickly.
So ecommerce,
super easy to do on Squarespace.
A No credit card is needed either.
You can just try it out and start building your website.
Um,
you try it and then if you don't like it,
you just go away.
But if you like it,
you enter in your credit card information after you've already tried out the
product,
they're that confident in it and they should be.
It's pretty bad ass.
And if you use the offer code,
J r e,
well actually no for GRE listeners,
if you go to use the offer code Joe and the number 12 Joe 12 one word Joe number
1212 for December,
you'll get 10% off your first purchase on new accounts.
So that's squarespace.com use the offer code,
all one word Joe and the number 12 and save yourself 10% you're freaks on an
awesome website.
It really works.
It's excellent.
Brian's done.
He's probably,
how many of you made a lot of time like Ari Shaffir,
his legs.com Bert squirt?
Bert?
I think it's one.
I don't even remember all that.
We just make group.
He makes nonsense websites while we're doing the commercial for the website.
It's really that easy,
but they put this thing now on where they're not letting me go past it because I
think they've caught onto me.
Oh,
those sons of bitches.
Listen,
folks,
we're trying to sell your websites.
Don't do that.
I can't go anywhere.
Why would they do that too?
It kind of hurt my feelings.
Did they on,
do they understand that we're promoting them while we're doing this?
Maybe they just think we're assholes.
Like somebody just started complaining about US folks.
We're just promoting Squarespace.
Jesus.
Louisa's
so sad.
So sad that Squarespace doesn't like your work.
I think I figured out what it is.
A work around.
Yeah.
What's the work around?
Hit the x in the corner.
Oh,
there's an x.
They just the video,
but the need the x really hard to see.
Oh really?
It's one of those I get offended by those.
I'm sorry.
I know I shouldn't,
but I fucking do.
I get offended.
I find that those pop up videos that you make me x out of those are gross.
That's like showing me your Dick.
You know,
it's like,
Hey,
you know why I,
you know,
I didn't come for that video.
Why
is it video popping up in the middle of your screen?
It's one thing if it's like an add on the beginning of the video because then I
went to a video,
I don't mind watching 15 seconds of whatever the fuck it is.
It's just,
you know,
I understand you have to sell advertisement,
but when a video comes out of nowhere,
that's rude.
Yeah.
That shits grows and if it crashes your system and you lose your work,
oh my God,
you want to fucking kill somebody.
But who's fault is that?
That's your fault.
Stupid.
Okay.
Don't get hostile.
Hope he,
uh,
that'd be blaming other people for your issues
were also brought to you by lumosity.com Lumosity is another new sponsor here at
the Joe Rogan experience podcast and it's essentially a gym for your brain.
It's a really cool setup.
I really enjoy it.
And uh,
I've,
I've done it and they're like little cool games that you play.
And the idea behind it is based on the science of neuroplasticity,
which is just a bunch of words I don't understand because I'm not that smart.
But uh,
according to smart people,
that's impressive.
And if you go to lumosity.com you can learn all about what,
what they can do and how customizable it is.
What they've done is they've set up their website.
If you go to lumosity.com what you see is a bunch of different options.
You have a bunch of different options on how to,
how to set up your,
um,
set up your program because they're very flexible.
It's all based on what you're looking for.
And if you're looking for like saying here,
I'm going here,
right?
Like if you're looking from memory,
they have like these options.
Like what are you looking to do?
You were looking to recall the location of objects.
Are you looking to remember names after the first introduction?
They have a bunch of different offerings like this,
a bunch of different options for each different facet of,
of training your brain like attention,
memory,
speed,
flexibility and the the,
the interesting thing about it is that it's not boring.
It's fun to do so you enjoy doing it while you're exercising your brain and
that's something we can all use folks.
Most of us have jobs that are kind of like similar,
a lot like days sort of melt in today's,
I think that Shit's bad for your brain and I think your brain needs a little
exercise and if you can't give it exercise in life,
it's probably good to give it exercise in the form of,
of games or have tests or play a little chess or something like that.
Just think you use it because I think it's like everything else.
I think it's like your lungs.
I think it's like your cardiovascular system.
I think the more you use it,
the healthier it is.
And I think when you don't use it,
it's,
there's a reason why so many fucking people are stupid.
Let's just say it.
If they went to lumosity.com and looked up problem solving,
they would have all sorts of options like dissecting complex arguments,
making quick and accurate estimations.
What I'm basically saying is get your shit together and go to lumosity.com Jesus
people.
Okay,
go to lumosity.com/joe
that's lumosity.com forward slash Joe Click the start training button and start
playing your first game.
It's lumosity.com/joe you really enjoy it.
It's interesting,
it's fun and you know it's that or play angry birds,
one of those fucking things at Dick's,
you to your phone.
Oh my God,
those are so bad for your dumb and there's so lovely.
He just gets so wrapped up in them.
You don't give a fuck about your plane flight or or anything else.
This is along those lines,
but actually good for you.
Guilt free,
guilt free,
fucking around.
So that's lumosity.com forward slash.
Joe We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
This is the last day of the big on its sale.
If you're listening to this live,
it's a,
today is December 2nd,
2013.
Um,
and uh,
on,
it's big sale ends tonight at midnight and it's like up to 25% off on a lot of
shit.
We have all sorts of shit on it would on is basically what we like to call it as
a human optimization website,
for lack of a better word.
And we just tried to sell you the best shit that we find as far as strength and
conditioning equipment,
vitamins,
nutrients,
things that I use,
things that I promote,
things that I think are important to recognize.
There's,
there's some supplements out there that fucking work all right,
and they're not dangerous,
they're not bad for you,
but they can give you a nice little boost and a lot of different areas in your
mood.
It's been proven that certain nutrients stimulate the production of brain
chemicals like Serotonin and five HTP is one of those.
And we have that in new mood,
which is a five HTP and l Tryptofan,
a supplement l Tryptofan,
which apparently converts to five HTP.
Again,
I'm just repeating shit that I don't even understand.
Just making words with my face.
He's,
when is on it going to step up their garlic game.
Still bump your garlic James.
It sounds like a pizza ad.
Super garlic pizza.
I'd teach her Rio who no fucks.
I've been taking this garlic supplements so like 1,002 thousand a day.
That's great.
Yeah.
That's good for you.
And I just went to a vitamin Shoppe,
you know,
and,
and there was some stuff that already had from on it but there was some stuff
that I couldn't find on on it.
Yeah.
We don't have everything that's for sure.
There's definitely room for a lot of new shit but um,
garlic is a super useful thing to take but I would recommend if you can deal
with it,
take it raw.
The life.
Yeah.
Because if you have any like stomach issues,
garlic is fantastic for like dealing with like food poisoning and stuff like
that.
Apparently garlic is just nuclear war for like bad bacteria.
And why and why is that not?
That should be more known.
I think super healthy plant,
you know,
super healthy Pete.
Pardon nature interacts with our body really well then fucking tastes great.
Yeah.
Cause we,
we grow up thinking mostly garlic,
you know,
it's like vampires and stuff like that thing and stinky breath.
I remember thinking stinky breath but there's a lot of shit that smells worse
than garlic breath,
like garlic press and of that bad,
you know,
it's not as bad as like,
you know a girl throws up a lot.
Yeah.
But now you,
do you ever have the girl that I had like a yeast problem where there they tell
you to put garlic in her vagina like you take,
what kind of crazy bitch are you dating and what mood doctor is she going to
know?
It's an unknown picking crops that are pussy.
You put a couple a glitter.
They loaves are a
couple of loaves and garlic,
clove,
cloves,
but a couple of cloves of garlic in there overnight and then,
but that,
that kills everything.
Yeah.
But that hasn't been horrible.
I wonder if it tastes bad when you go down on her,
whatever it has,
it changes the flavor of our vagina.
It's like,
imagine if your vagina was like Jello.
It just absorb whatever flavor you're toss anyway.
Like,
well,
garlic probably would do that for a while.
Wouldn't it would absorb into those lips?
No.
Well,
that's the thing that the vagina is very absorbable.
That's how you can get pregnant.
Super easy with it.
Like it's open tissue.
That's also why women are more susceptible to catching HIV,
apparently.
Allegedly.
Because you know God comes inside of them.
Their body absorbs it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I would think,
I would think garlic would have a little bit of an impact,
but like if I like it a little bit of 22 it anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com the sale ends tonight@midnightandwhenawhennotanana.com
uh,
when the sales not on,
rather@ana.com use the offer code Rogan and save yourself 10% off any and all
supplements.
She and the bell here play the music,
Brian.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
My night all day
today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
today is December 2nd,
2013 and 50 years ago today,
the first mixed martial arts fight was fought in America 60,
right?
60 years ago today.
What does the,
what is the date of it?
Uh,
December 2nd,
1963.
Yeah,
so was 50 years ago.
I was three at the time
and the man in front of me,
uh,
judo,
gene labelle,
who,
uh,
I've known and I've been very fortunate to be your friend for it,
right.
A number of years and it's been a real honor.
I'm your guide that,
uh,
amongst like mixed martial arts fighters,
like especially even early in the day,
you were like really keenly involved in,
I don't know if [inaudible] the right word to use there,
but very involved in the education of martial artists about grappling.
Uh,
Joe,
what I always liked to do when I was a kid to get the point over,
you shouldn't just do grappling,
which I know you're a great,
you're an expert at grappling and I,
I admire you because you've been there and done that.
But along with grappling,
you should learn.
Boxing.
Campo showed a contact quando gung fu,
Greco Roman wrestling,
freestyle wrestling,
motorcycle riding.
Oh,
a little bit of everything.
And of course,
myself,
when I was young,
I got kicked out of the judo gems because guys beating me up.
I hit him with the left talk,
then I'd go to the boxing gym.
The guy beat me up there and I body slam him.
So,
and I got kicked out.
I got kicked out.
I got the Guinness Book of Records that get kicked out of gyms.
But you taught Bruce Lee,
uh,
some judo,
didn't you?
Yes,
I said,
dad,
what was that like?
Well,
he a great guy,
one of the best athletes you'd ever want to see.
A nice guy.
Uh,
I worked a lot.
I have a TV shows with him and uh,
of course he was famous for doing enter the Dragon.
He wanted me to go on that show and he says,
you'll make $200 a week now then,
you know,
30 years ago,
that was big money.
Uh,
but I was making a thousand a week doing westerns.
And so,
uh,
I says,
I think I'll stay.
But,
uh,
it became,
um,
a call to the most famous martial arts movie ever was enter the Dragon,
but it was done in Hong Kong,
not union.
And you know the difference between Union and non union.
So you don't really get a piece of that.
You don't get any residuals.
Look at these pictures of you.
Handsome Young,
pastored a beautiful man.
Oh yeah.
Now you can see how actually small,
uh,
go co,
this guy,
uh,
Bruce Lee was,
while he was a very small man,
uh,
it short Gretta athletes and I ran this dance on this where he picks me up.
Well,
you,
you know,
it's really fascinating that there was so much learning going on at the time and
that's one of the things that I think people are so compelled to,
uh,
to,
it's one of the reasons why they're so compelled to learn about Bruce Lee
because he was really the first guy that said,
let's just try everything and mix it all together.
And was like really public and out front about it.
And his martial arts that he created called Jeet Cuno.
The whole philosophy is that it was used what is useful and he credits you with
a,
a lot of the,
uh,
development of his,
grappling,
understanding,
grappling.
I think a lot of fighters back in that day,
they didn't really understand that you needed to know all aspects of martial
arts.
And if you didn't know how to grapple,
you fairly help us when a grappler gets a hold of you.
Yeah.
And they did a lot of forms there.
But uh,
with all due respect,
uh,
Bruce taught me a lot of techniques that I use in the movies.
Jumping,
spinning kicks course.
I launched that about 20 years ago.
I still look all over the kitchen floor for my spinning kick,
but it's gone.
Uh,
he was a great athlete and any can beat a guy or a woman you learn from what
they have to teach,
then use cause.
Say,
well now that I know what,
I'll just tell everybody I invented it.
And when you're training with him,
you know,
was,
was there this sense of who he was at that time?
Did anybody have any idea how that was all going to go down and how he was going
to,
essentially,
for a lot of people represent martial arts when we talk about martial arts
today,
still to this day in 2013,
people bring up Bruce Lee.
Uh,
he is a god now,
you know?
Yeah.
And,
uh,
he was just a little guy that put too much starch in my shirt.
So once a week,
uh,
he didn't have it sense of humor until he stayed with me for a while and found
out it was just a tease.
Greg,
he would have been a,
uh,
a champion in the martial arts,
the MMA,
and you'll be interviewing him instead of me if he was still alive.
So you knew at the time while you were working with them that he was a unique
guy,
very unique,
very well coordinated.
Uh,
he was creator and a lot of the people that did his style,
I sort of didn't,
didn't like him because he wasn't traditional.
He learned to do boxing,
he learned to do a grappling for me,
uh,
judo.
And as you can see earlier,
some of those judo moves that we did 104 years ago.
Yeah.
But it was still a in color.
Maybe the color colored it,
but uh,
he loved that.
He loved that because he was a good athlete.
He was a good tumbler and a great human being.
I have been blessed a Joe and uh,
meeting people and they'd come family like your family to me.
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah.
Family to me.
What do I call you?
Well,
uncle gene,
uncle gene.
Rhonda does what has forever.
Everybody has.
Yeah.
All the stunt guys on fear factor used to call you uncle genes ad sent.
Uh,
but with you,
you know,
you have to,
I want to raise in my allowance,
you know.
Um,
so when you are,
are you training with any fighters today?
Like I know you've done some work with Rhonda and the past.
I train with guys,
but mostly beginners.
The,
the thing is what I try to do.
So many people helped me when I was beginning in the martial art world and in
this dot worker world.
Now it's payback time.
And uh,
I tried to help people out.
I do judge here in California and uh,
I did used to referee.
Um,
and that was hard.
I had to learn to count to 10.
Uh,
I was lucky to referee Muhammad Ali in a Gnocchi,
which was a big thing,
mixed martial light event in Tokyo,
Japan,
you know,
and uh,
so I've been there.
I had done that.
So anytime I can help somebody out,
hey,
I get a pleasure out of it.
Yeah,
I'm sure you do.
You,
you really enjoy teaching and you always have taught,
uh,
Silvio Pimento,
who I trained with Silverado Silverado over John jocks.
He was one of your black belts,
right?
That's true.
Great Guy.
Very,
very intelligent guy.
Very technical guy.
I learned a lot from that guy.
I learned a lot of what you taught them as well.
A lot of our leg locks,
which uh,
the Brazilians long time ago didn't do lake locks.
And now they're into it and they're into a lot of things that were not
sanctioned by their methods.
Yeah,
there was a time,
it was a lot of folks don't realize this,
that Jujitsu,
they had a bias against attacking the legs.
Like if he went for a leg lock or a heel hook,
the crowd would boo and hiss.
And it became like a weird thing because it didn't make any sense because like
the Samba guys were using leg locks,
the catch guys were using leg locks and they would go in against Jujitsu guys.
And a lot of Jujitsu guys were not prepared for it because they didn't really
think that it was a valid technique.
For whatever reason.
It didn't make any sense.
But now you got guys like Paul Harris,
who's a Brazilian guy who was probably one of the best in the world at it.
Fantastic.
He's,
uh,
he's great.
Uh,
one of my coach,
uh,
was,
Karl gotch was his name passed away a few years ago.
Uh,
he used to take Olympic champions and having for lunch and the Brazilian guys
that did the guard,
he loved it.
They roll on the back,
put the feed up,
and he would break her leg.
I never saw him miss breaking your leg.
Wow.
And uh,
you know,
as a sexual thing for me at all,
he was an animal.
Well,
breaking a leg means good luck.
And uh,
before it was the guard in wrestling,
they called it foot and leg control and uh,
but it's all the same thing.
Uh,
you control the lower body theoretically with your legs and,
and just attack the joint from an angle.
And then you go into a,
you can switch and go into a triangle net joke or an arm bar or a,
if you're good at spinning to decide,
you can also get a knee lock.
So there's basically a lot of the techniques that you see today,
you Jitsu techniques like the guard there really,
they were really kind of always around and catch.
They just had different names and they just were more,
maybe more,
uh,
observe today are more analyzed today,
and improved on the MMA.
And uh,
uh,
Dana white is,
I mean,
he's the best promoter that ever lived.
And I liked the gentlemen,
uh,
he's got all these guys together and they have to [inaudible] improvement.
You have to,
every year somebody comes up with a new technique,
which is an old technique with a different name.
Uh,
it's,
it's kind of a important now years ago,
uh,
you know how they got the name that you use all the time?
The camera?
Yeah.
From the guy who fought Helio Gracie.
Yes.
But he was a judo champion.
And in judo they kicked him out of Japan because he wanted to go pro as a
wrestler,
which he did.
So he go down and he'd beat everybody with a double wrist lock,
a dominant arm crank.
And uh,
so they couldn't pronounce double wrist lock or downward arm crank.
So they said the camera,
you know,
and that's based on the move that beat Leo.
He,
yeah,
but he beat a lot of guys and the,
the progress,
there's a Karl Gotch,
uh,
he'd beat everybody with that hold,
but he did it a little bit different.
He had braked the wrist,
the elbow,
the,
and the shoulder where most of the people,
they just,
uh,
break the elbow and the shoulder.
We,
you know,
when I talked to Josh Barnett about the difference between catch wrestling and
Brazilian Jujitsu of being charged about as big an expert as any you could ask
for in this country,
like active fighters that really understands,
catch what he calls catch the violent art.
He's like,
Jujitsu is a general art catches the violent art.
It's much more violent approach.
It's all just grappling.
It's still just grappling,
but a much more violent approach to attaining the positions,
wrestling based attacks to attain the positions.
Whereas Jujitsu guys try to move around things.
A wrestler who go through it.
Josh Burnett has been a friend of mine for 104 years.
He's a young man and it looks beautiful for a hundred,
four years old.
Is he a vampire or perhaps a way he takes that botox so bad for you?
Some time to stop and look.
He gave passes for still in his late thirties.
Uh,
but he did work a little bit of Karl gotch and the feel good,
uh,
pros.
He's got a great trainer now and uh,
uh,
I,
I can hardly wait to,
uh,
December 28th and watch him.
He's on that card.
Yeah.
Against Travis Browne should be very,
very interesting.
Well,
it,
Travis Browne is no slouch.
Oh,
he's as tough as they come.
It doesn't get any tougher than that guy.
Oh,
well how about you?
Never impossible.
I'm too dumb for that.
Um,
the,
uh,
Travis Browne,
Alistair Overeem fight highlighted.
Dot.
I mean,
he took just tremendous shots to the body that a lot of people would have folded
up shop on.
I've,
I've never seen anybody take dot kind of a beating and the beginning around and
come back to knock guy out with a head kick afterwards.
It was incredible.
That's his,
that's like heart and will,
you know that you can't,
you can't measure that.
But Barnett,
Scott that to Barnett's an animal,
you know,
if you don't beat Barnett and he comes back,
I mean,
he's always in that fight.
He's not,
he doesn't fold up shop ever.
He sees a solid,
solid veteran too.
He's a sneaky dude.
Like he knows his way around shit.
He's in there and done that.
Very,
very smart guy.
You know,
we had him on the podcast and people were blown away.
I get so many text messages and tweets from people going,
how is it?
This guy gets punched in the head for a living and he's 10 times smarter than
me.
Like five different people said that to me.
Uh,
drastic Jasper net.
I'll go up to them,
I'll say,
Hey Josh,
show me the comber.
And he had grabbed me.
There's an outside child as a double rich slide downward.
I'm Craig and then he'll put it on me.
I loved the man.
Yeah,
he's all catch.
He keeps the torch lit,
right?
Yeah.
Well the,
as far as like top level fighters,
he certainly does well.
He's been alarmed a long time and he's got a lot to teach.
There's a lot to talk about and a lot to show.
Very,
very smart guy too.
What do you think?
Like as far as like Karl Gotch,
one of the things that he's known for is not just a teaching,
a lot of guys catch wrestling submissions,
but also it's conditioning Regina.
It's conditioning regimen.
It's supposed to be one of the most grueling ever.
Like they said that they would,
he would make guys do 500 bodyweight squats before they could even practice.
Uh,
he did,
he had me working for a few years with,
uh,
these weights with a handle on it.
Mace balls.
We sell those@ana.com as a manger or the whatever he used,
um,
night 90 a white kettle balls.
He called 90 pounds.
Yeah.
Kettlebells.
And uh,
I still have 40 fives.
Um,
but when I worked with him,
I was 180 pounds and he was like two 60.
Jesus Christ.
He's a giant man too.
It was a big,
like a big,
like European boned to 60.
Yeah.
But [inaudible] he was,
you didn't see any fat or no,
none at all.
And the thing I liked about him,
he was a sadistic bastard.
I've heard that about you.
Uh,
you must have the Silverado bus go that and I'm just a little trivia.
Everybody wants to know why they call you uncle gene.
While I've been in 13 hall of Fames,
I've won tournaments all over the world.
My proudest thing is when people call me uncle gene because with the old
restors,
the real,
what they called shooters,
you finally got to a stage which nobody got too,
and if you could get a bunch of guys and make them yell uncle like I,
uh,
then afterwards they awarded me,
now your uncle jade,
how did it become uncle?
One of them cry uncle.
But,
but how did that figure of speech is so strange?
Like why would you cry uncle to get someone to stop?
Which doesn't make any sense.
I don't know.
But at that time,
that's what they say.
I instead I give up.
They say uncle,
I remember that from,
I don't know if kids didn't even understand that cry uncle,
do they?
I grew up with it.
Yeah,
but you're a 40,
and I'm talking about like 20 year olds.
Like he forgets he's not a kid anymore.
He's the kids in a perpetual state of kidneys.
Um,
I only think kids today use that expression.
No.
Well,
uh,
expressions change since in the last 20 years.
You know,
you got to have a,
a cell phone.
You got to
[inaudible] do all those things on the Internet.
Do you take selfies?
Do you do like selfies for Instagram ever?
No.
I'm from the old school where you have to die all the phone.
I got up to draw pictures of people.
Oh no cameras.
Ghada Ghada
and I think you taught it to me.
When you use the change,
buy diapers,
what is it like going through a,
all these different generations?
Like I grew up in the 70s and uh,
you know,
I,
uh,
I was around before the Internet was around,
you know,
I went to high school in the 80s and uh,
I graduated from high school in 1985.
So I've been around a long time to the,
the change has been pretty interesting.
But for you like being from the error of like Bruce Lee movies and like you
were,
you were a national judo champion in 1954 and that's incredible.
That's a long time ago.
I mean,
how much,
how much different is the world today than it was then?
Um,
everything changes.
And uh,
you got to change with it.
54 and 55,
two years.
And then I turned pro.
Um,
things change and you gotta be up on it.
I,
uh,
I'm not,
I try,
I've got computers all over the place and,
uh,
all I look at it,
you got mail and see who the hell I hates me today.
Uh,
and a few other little things,
but the kids nowadays,
the teachings,
they have to learn how to do a computer cell phones.
There is,
there's more to everything.
So that you think is the biggest difference between when you were a kid in
today's just the Internet.
Uh,
the Internet technology,
uh,
the cars,
the gadget,
look at the electrical stuff.
They have the flat screen TV.
I had to be on steroids to pick up a TV
20 years ago.
They used to be big giant cabinets.
Remember those things.
They're like furniture and a little tiny screen in it.
Screen was only about 12 inches wide
and the TV thing was huge.
All that equipment and everything back there.
Now everything's flat screen and uh,
had a record player on the top.
Oh yeah,
always record.
You are old.
And they had cabinet doors.
Remember they had cabinet doors,
they swung open things,
slides so you can hide the TV.
You know,
I kind of just like weird.
Yeah.
The old days.
Um,
for me it's fascinating.
But for you,
I mean I'm watching these videos of you when you were young man and you're doing
these fight scenes with Bruce Lee and I think,
wow,
this guy is,
you've seen everything.
I mean you've seen so much.
You've seen the changing of the perceptions of martial arts for the first time
with those Bruce Lee movies.
That was the first changing of perception of martial arts.
The first real introduction to the Western world and a mainstream way was Bruce
Lee movies.
Cause before that none of those other martial arts things ever really got
traction.
Like he did,
but he was all a sudden,
it was like,
Whoa,
I want to learn how to do that.
That guy's amazing.
The showmanship and his dynamic presence and his speed and his techniques.
Like nobody had ever seen anything like that before.
So we saw this Bruce Lee guy and all of a sudden everybody's talking about
martial arts and then,
but you've had a chance to see that you've had a chance to see,
like I said,
you were involved in the first ever mixed martial arts fight and now seeing the
UFC grow to become what it is today.
You've been there through the introduction to the latest evolution.
Uh,
it's a changing experience.
Like my event,
uh,
50 years ago today was the first sanctioned televised,
mixed martial art event.
And now the rules have changed.
That's why I say,
uh,
when I choke the guy out and he was a great,
great,
great fighter.
Milo savage,
uh,
and the referee who was also a doctor,
couldn't revive him.
If as somebody like
a big John McCarthy was there,
he'd,
he'd had been able to revive the guy.
You mean not,
not dead.
You mean speeding?
It was unconscious.
Oh yeah,
give cops too,
which is a arted reviving a called Kaatsu Kaatsu and that was just,
was that rubbing the neck or something like?
Well,
it's getting the heart going where it pumps blood to the head.
When you choke a man out,
you're not choking him.
You're slowing down the blood supply to his head til he passes unconscious.
Now I broke guys legs and arms and stuff like that and they got a permanent
injury.
You choke a guy out,
ted,
seconds later you'll revive him.
He's okay ghetto
rather than getting knocked out to a lot of people think it's the same thing.
The people that don't understand martial arts,
so big,
big,
big difference.
Getting choked out like this.
Really no ill effects.
The real effects,
uh,
come from striking.
Really?
Oh I agree with you.
And that's how you get brain concoctions and that dead.
Then you're having trouble when you're talking gun.
Bit Punchy and guys wrong me there and got gone
up there.
You guys,
are you making fun of guys with brain damage?
That's weird.
I only saw gene,
this,
uh,
we've,
we've all known guys that have gotten punching and that's the dirty aspect of
this.
This game of mixed martial arts itself is like,
there's guys that do the wrong thing and they stay when they shouldn't have
stayed and they take shots it shouldn't have taken.
And then we get to see that damage.
And it's very disturbing.
It's something that people don't ever want to think is going to happen to them.
And that's why I always give this encouragement that if anybody's thinking of
retiring,
retire,
if you're thinking of it at all,
I,
you know,
something,
you,
you're right on the numbers right down the numbers.
You're never,
you're always have the feeling.
Now in my eighties,
I still have the feeling of getting on the mat and I said,
Jesus guys making a mistake,
you know,
but I gotta concentrate on teaching the guy and not trying to prove myself.
Well,
you just,
competitive fires never really,
totally burned out.
No.
Uh,
the rest of my is burned out though.
Um,
it's important.
That's why I say to Rhonda,
I'm sure glad she got into the movies and so when the time comes,
like Joe Lewis or Cassius clay,
they have another place to go.
Randy couture was a good friend of mine.
Now he does.
He's not competing anymore,
but he does a movie.
Yeah,
he's translated the best.
He's done the very best job of transferring from MMA stardom to movie stardom,
enacting stardom.
And he's,
he's works a lot now.
I have more power to him.
He's good too.
You know,
he was good,
very bendable.
He's very calm,
very relaxed.
Like you know what made him a great fighter will make him a great actor.
I think
that's good.
You when you,
Amanda doesn't think of the future,
doesn't have one.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
well he's a terrible example to use though because the guy fought til he was 48.
I mean [inaudible] he was just incredible.
He's a terrible example.
And you used to get out when you,
you know,
when you think you should get out,
get out because he came back,
you know,
he was going to retire after the second chocolate Dell fine.
Then he came back,
won the heavyweight title.
Randy coture has gone through a whole whirlwind.
So maybe I really should just shut the fuck up.
I tell people when to retire and whatnot.
Randy's also fine.
I mean,
you talked to him,
he's totally lucid speaks clearly.
You know,
he did a good job of protecting himself with a lot of his grappling,
you know,
because he was a very good grappler.
Always very solid and intelligent,
really good at executing g game plans.
But everybody takes shots.
You just got,
they got to know when to not take anymore.
It's so hard to figure out to staff who wants to retire when they're on top.
Yup.
And he wants to retire when they still feel like they can beat a lot of dudes
acids.
And you know,
a lot of guys that just for one or two times too long.
Yup,
Yup.
Or more,
you know,
unfortunately we were the money's there and uh,
it's hard to pass up a yeah.
But when you're putting you the only initiative,
the veteran you have in life is your body,
you got to take care of it the best way you can.
This weird things that happened to like,
uh,
like Bob Sapp is an example of one of the weird things that happened in MMA
where the guy becomes sort of a traveling road show and just goes and fights
guys and tops quick and moves onto the next town and sort of like selling the
name that he made when he was in pride,
when he was one of the scariest guys on earth.
And He seems like he's just not really there competitively anymore,
but he does a lot of fights,
has a lot of fights.
And that's how he's making a living,
I guess.
Well,
let's help.
Uh,
pray to God.
He doesn't get a permanent,
uh,
damage,
injury.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
unfortunately,
one of the great old school legends,
uh,
Gary Goodrich,
he's been real public about his issues and how,
how much,
um,
pugilistic dementia,
which is what the medical term for punching punch truck.
Yeah.
And He,
he's talking pretty openly about it to,
you know,
alert young fighters to the,
the risks and you know,
and talk about what he basically says it was k one that did the men basically
says that fighting and MMA was one thing,
but the amount of blows that he would take and k one was just substantially
greater.
You know what I mean?
Those guys were so high level too.
That's why it is so important to have a great referee.
And there's a lot of good ones here in Nevada all over the world.
And there's a lot of ones that aren't that sharp.
Uh,
they don't know when to stop a fight and a guy,
I'll take just one or two blows where he's can't protect himself and a then
it's,
she had rummy.
Yeah.
And those,
those blows after guys are out,
are very dangerous.
You know,
those are,
those are really bad ones.
That was the ones,
the rep,
and it's oftentimes,
it's not the fighters fault.
The fighter is hitting them because they're in a zone and they don't even know
what they're doing.
They're trying to finish this guy.
They're not even thinking.
They're barely even aware.
They might,
they might think he's almost out.
But what if he wakes up?
What if he wakes up and does this to me?
And they're trying to end that fight.
It's the referee's job to be objective and to see it and to get in there before
those unnecessary blows take place.
But that's a tough gig.
I mean,
you've done it before and you've been there for a hundred MMA fights or at least
a hundred events.
I mean,
I've seen you at so many of them when there's moments where a guy just isn't in
the right position,
maybe a strange technique lands and no one expects a head kick that no one saw
common and the guy goes down and by the time the referee gets to him,
he's already getting hit two and three times while he's already unconscious.
It's really common.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a,
that's a fact that I've seen so many guys that are injured and I was,
had a judging one of the,
uh,
tournaments.
Uh,
and one of the competitors had a Hematoma,
which is a blood pressure.
Claire around his head.
Worst I've ever seen.
I've seen a lot of them from boxing and uh,
the doctor was playing with a ring girls and uh,
they didn't,
uh,
stop the fight and I said,
Jesus,
they should have stopped the fight.
And uh,
you know,
he went the full three rounds,
but I mean,
he looked like a hamburger.
You,
there's a,
some people get busted up.
There's a weird moment,
like when do you stop a fight?
Do you stop a fight when a guy's head is swollen misshapen?
Like did you see a mark harmonic versa?
Josie Aldo.
Yeah,
he had that crazy giant lump on his head that looked like yet,
like someone had inserted a small football underneath his forehead.
Remember that?
But he fought well,
even though he had that,
he fought well.
So that's like one of those things where it gets that weird blurry line.
Like,
how do you stop this fight?
Like he's,
he won the last round.
I mean,
Hammock took,
although down here it was in his guard,
he was ground and pounding him pretty,
pretty clearly one the last round.
So,
even with this big giant lump on his head,
you know,
he's still doing well in the fight.
Yeah,
he's doing well.
Wait 10 years when he starts having headaches.
So you think that like when you see like an outside thing,
swelling outside the skin where all that blood,
they should just stop a fight.
Well,
uh,
let me put it this
and I have debates and it's my opinion,
right?
I've had debates with doctors.
When a guy gets hit from football,
he gets knocked out or a glove.
What happens if you get hit in the arm?
It swells up.
Same thing with the uh,
brain.
It swells up.
And a lot of people,
they won't do anything right away.
Cause I'm from the boxing ward world,
we put ice on right away.
Now here's what happens.
I was told by Dr. Bernard Swartz
50 or 60 years ago that
when the brain swells it,
there's bones around your head and it pushes the brain,
pushes against the bones of your head and it gives you a brain injury.
It kills
okay
part of your brain.
So,
you know,
make sure that I put ice,
always carry ice.
If a guy gets knocked out from a blow,
you put ice on his head,
try to get the swelling down that keep the swelling down like you would do for a
need,
just like you would do for an elbow.
You do it for the head as well.
Absolutely.
How come people don't know that?
Well,
people do.
I,
I've talked to a newer surgeons,
doctors did they puff,
puff,
they say they,
that that isn't what I do.
I give them this medicine or that medicine.
And I said by that time he's already screwed up yet.
Oh.
And uh,
I've been there,
I've done that.
I've been around boxing and wrestling for 75 years.
Wow.
And,
uh,
and that just not once every month.
That's every day.
That's my life,
you know.
And,
uh,
I've see injuries and I,
I've seen being doing stunts.
I be see people that have crashed cars and they just,
they want to put them on a Gurney to put ice on their head.
And I've seen a stuntman come out punchy from impacts for,
so the people don't realize how many stuntman get injured every year.
I mean people,
a lot of them die as well.
I mean I've heard of many stunt men dying while filming crazy action for scenes
in movies,
especially car accidents,
motorcycle accidents.
It's very common.
It's a very,
very,
very rough business.
I had a friend of mine,
Mike Tillman was his name and he,
he uh,
had a freak accident and the car,
it's split his helmet and um,
uh,
they didn't put ice on them and then wondered why.
And he finally came out of it long time,
but later he only lived at year admin.
I knew him real well.
We used to go motorcycle riding racing every weekend and he didn't even know me.
And I says,
wow.
So the most dangerous thing to me is a brain injury.
I agree.
I agree hard.
A lot more research on it.
Is that you and Rodney Dangerfield?
Did you double as Rodney?
I did double him a few times.
Oh God.
A couple of TV shows I had was a picture of you guys up there.
What's that?
My God.
Can you say,
uh,
yeah,
I uh,
we,
I was doing sword fighting then sword fighting.
Oh yeah,
definitely him and uh,
he was quite a character,
quite a character.
He would always leave his pants unzip and um,
I had uh,
one of the actors of,
I'm saying,
hey,
his pants inside zip.
He'd go up and he says,
I'm getting air conditioning.
Don't bother me.
And he just did it as a swerve a joke,
right?
With like the robes and stuff.
Well,
I've talked about this before,
but I worked at great woods,
a concert center and Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
When I was a kid I was a,
amongst the security personnel there.
And so I was backstage and I got to see Rodney as he was preparing for a show.
He would just have a robe on and nothing else.
And we were wearing slippers and he had a robe on and he was walking around back
there.
This is before I'd ever done standup comedy,
but I was like,
that guy is the shit.
Like,
look at him.
He's just,
he's literally as comfortable as you can get.
He's wearing a bathrobe on purpose and it's because he could,
you know,
he was like,
cause I can whatever,
I'm just gonna wear a bathrobe.
It's comfortable and light the
way I,
the way you'll
roared.
He does it because he can because he keeps fucking Ronnie did.
He knew he was Rodney Dangerfield and no,
never said anything and he played it straight.
And apparently a super nice guy.
I like everybody I know that did business with them or had any interactions with
them,
always came away from it.
Same Rodney,
he's a great guy.
My friend Jeff,
my manager Jeff,
he was with one of,
uh,
one of his clients was one of Rodney's original,
um,
uh,
comics on the Hbo Comedy Series that he did.
And uh,
he said that Rodney was just the best,
just the coolest,
nicest guy.
Yeah.
And what I've said to you,
a lot of sense of humor.
He was in a real original too.
He was a handle,
but a stand up comedian.
And of course he's not as good as you.
You're my hero,
I get out of here.
But he was also a great actor too.
Did you ever see back back to school?
The movie with him and Kinison was in that movie?
Yeah.
It was fucking hilarious in that movie.
Those were classics when I was a kid.
You know,
those were like,
those are some of the,
in my opinion,
some of the most enjoyable comedy moves that I ever saw was a Rodney Dangerfield
once.
It was just a feeling that you had for the whole thing.
Like it would just see the guy and you would want a laugh.
You know,
you don't see a lot of the like the old comedians,
uh,
anymore.
Very seldom.
What do you mean?
Like which guys?
Well,
anything that I got a Bob Hope,
uh,
they like that kind of
a Rodney Dangerfield,
Jack Benny,
uh,
people that were stand up comedians.
Uh,
there is no show that I know that really
showboats I know he's saying like,
um,
you used to be the tonight show with Johnny Carson.
That was like the big thing that was like the big show boat or showcase.
Have you got on the tonight show with Johnny Carson and Johnny Carson pulled you
next to him on the couch.
Whoa.
Wow.
You're made.
You're made man.
You,
you made it.
You've gone through the hallowed halls,
the guy,
the man gave you the seat on the couch.
That was a big deal.
This is not really a thing like that anymore.
But now there's the internet and the Internet has kind of changed the whole
rules for how media gets out there to people.
And there's a lot of people that the odds of you being at home and 11 o'clock on
a Wednesday night,
those are not that good.
You know,
you probably have things to do.
You're probably up in your round.
They a number of actual people who are going to see that.
It's very limited.
But if you went on some TV show somewhere and then they put the clip online,
then the clip online,
you could watch anytime you want.
So then it spreads like wildfire.
So now all you have to do is have something online and all it is is judo.
Gene Lebell says,
this is hilarious.
And He sends it to Brian Red Band.
Brian Red Band sends it to me.
I sent it to Brian Callen and goes across the country.
That's what happens today.
And you'd get these unheralded kids that,
uh,
do a stand up on,
on like a youtube channel.
They're like doing it to a camera
and they get hundreds of thousands of views,
seats,
codes,
and we're very,
very strict as famous.
You can get famous real easy.
Now I get a kick out.
I shouldn't say that.
That doesn't make sense.
Well,
when I say accessible,
famous,
like when I'm judging around California,
people come up,
they want to take a picture.
I'm in my eighties,
and they wanted an autograph.
Uh,
something like that.
And I says to my wife,
Jesus,
at that age,
uh,
the before I was,
when I was good,
these people weren't even born.
And it makes you feel good.
She calls me [inaudible] center of attraction.
You're the center of attraction.
Jolene.
And I want to thank you again for that tape.
You did me.
We won't get into it.
But it was Oh,
the documentary on you?
Yeah,
that was hilarious.
I,
I've got it on my computer and if somebody wants to see who my hero is,
I says,
here's Joe Rogan and how dare you.
Yeah.
There Eugene Labelle.
Um,
there's a,
a documentary on you that,
uh,
that roots of fight did write the,
the tee shirt company.
I,
yeah.
When is that out now?
I don't know.
The first thing I gotta buy.
Your business partner doesn't tell me anything.
She just says,
sign here and your business partner,
your wife and the whole God know what she used to Canadian.
Uh,
uh,
no,
her name is Kelly and a lover of mad late.
Uh,
but,
uh,
she,
she says this is the way it's going to be done.
I've been in business with so many different people that I got the short end of
the stick,
so she doesn't let me know too much.
But I did see the tape of different people talking about me,
uh,
that I was in pressed,
you know,
kind of funny.
Uh,
uh,
Ge,
Bj Penn and I didn't think a lot of these people would remember me.
Of course Rhonda does a Rhonda
as Mother Anna Maria who was a world champion.
Hey Brian,
I'm sending you a link right now on your,
uh,
Gmail to,
that,
uh,
the documentary.
It's an email.
I forwarded you the email,
but inside the email there's a link to the film that the roots of fight guys
have done.
They've done a quite a few of these documentaries on a bunch of different
martial artists.
So this one that they're doing on you,
they're real excited about,
especially considering today is the big 50th anniversary that Milo savage fight.
That's a law a lot of years.
Uh,
in fact,
uh,
John McCarthy was wearing one of those t shirts.
Uh,
and I said,
sure,
this is great.
How do I,
uh,
by one?
And he says,
well,
I'll fix it up and I must,
uh,
sounded stupid.
And to him,
cause I didn't even know it was they were making him at the time.
Here it is.
Here's the,
this is the video itself.
Jean overcame an enormous amount of racism throughout his career.
He was a real ground breaker and just so many ways.
Judo gene is overload.
The guy can do it all.
He can do submissions,
you can do judo,
you can do MMA.
He's a real deal.
I'm very lucky to have somebody like oncogene in my life to really be a guide
and a mentor back in the forties and fifties before the term is cross training
and mixed martial arts existed.
Gene labelle was already doing it and this is a guy who at the age of seven and
started training with Ed Strangling Lewis who's arguably the greatest catches
catch can wrestler his generation.
Then he moved on at the age of 11 to train in the main street boxing gym where
some of the greatest boxers of all time trained and he even ended up sparring
with sugar ray Robinson.
I was a young kid at main street gym and a sugar Ray Robinson came in with his
hair grease down and he looked beautiful.
He had his initials on his convertible Cadillac and he got on the ring and his
sparring partner in show out.
So,
uh,
how he's Diana says,
anybody want to work out with the sugar man as is.
Yeah.
If he isn't afraid of me.
And other words when your head is this big,
no good boxes [inaudible] and the first round he hit me 300 times.
He taught me a couple of things.
Gene's decision to take up judo in addition to boxing and catch wrestling was a
tougher one to make them.
A lot of people realize
he comes in this big white guy,
red hair,
obviously not Japanese and wants to learn their thing.
And a lot of people just said go away.
Gene went to train at a predominantly Japanese Dojo.
Some of the people who trained there had even been held in American internment
camps.
Even the ones that let him work out,
she's tried to beat the crap out of it,
but gene willingly went in there.
He took a students role.
He got his black kick day after day after day,
and yes,
endured discrimination in order to pick up the skills that he needed to call
himself a judo guy in essentially a judo champion.
Not only did he win the national championship,
but then they also had a grand champion ship pulls with the winner all the way
to patients and he won that too.
This guy went against the grain at every single opportunity.
He never took the easy road.
That attitude translates directly into why he picked up the Milo savage
challenge.
There was a magazine called rogue magazine and it said judo bumps.
Jim Beck offered a thousand dollars Danny [inaudible],
he couldn't be fed.
Parker came to me with his magazine and he says,
we want you to buy it as why me?
He says,
Jane,
everybody knows you the most sadistic bastard in the world.
So he ended up in 1963 Salt Lake City,
Utah.
This is a time weight watchers were considered to be the 100% best all round
fighters in the world,
but gene didn't care.
He was willing to take his style and put it into the competitive arena with the
whole world watching.
So when I'm going to fight instead of Jim Beck,
they do in a ringer,
Milo savage and Michael Savage was a rated rider,
number five in the world at the time.
A guy who had a pedigree of putting people to sleep with 10 ounce gloves on and
he's only wearing force.
My coach said,
you're not going to fight this guy.
Did he ever hit you in the face?
They'll come out the other side.
This is a 100% pro boxing crowd.
People were talking a lot of shit and saying that like,
you know,
Gina fires from bombs and I got there,
they said no kicking.
It was strictly judo.
Gene wasn't supposed to punch me low and Bulow had to wear the jeans,
you know,
top and stuff.
So your gene was at a real serious disadvantages.
He had to get a closer space without being able to throw his hands.
So when we get in the ring,
he has a karate,
he builds the Greece.
And I don't mean to put Vaseline,
it get,
it wasn't a judo gear was a chronic givers was like a very thin material,
but it was salt lake city.
You could do what you want,
you don't win.
It may have to have a plan.
I didn't get close to him and when I got close a drop my left arm,
so he'd throw a right,
so when you throw away and it went underneath and hook them and clenched him.
Jean threw him around a couple of times.
I have some to get lucky and throw them in a judo throw and land on him and then
I got behind him to choke him and he grabbed my thumb and started to bite it.
I said,
Milo,
you bite my finger.
I'm going to take your eye out his mouth.
When gene finally came to grips on that top and got ahold of savages,
drove,
it was all over and I reached down and I choked him out.
It was a boxing embrace it and I want to choke was and so Jean Chunk of out for
awhile.
He did not get up.
One Minute,
two minutes,
five minutes after he was choked out for my elbow was sitting down there and
when I walked I accidentally stepped up.
Dynamo,
good guy,
bad guy.
Dynamic flights at the crowd just became completely unhinged.
People started throwing chairs and pillows and in Salt Lake City,
that's the way of saying,
Oh you put on a great show.
We loved him.
They didn't want to acknowledge the result.
You didn't want to acknowledge that an Asian martial art had overcome what is
essentially an American martial art box and you take nothing away from Milo
savage.
You'd knocked out quite a few of martial artists before he met,
but the other marker water said he beach didn't grow up in boxing and uh,
I did.
You can't really understate the importance of the savage versus labelle fight.
That was the first time that somebody stepped up and said,
look,
grappling styles can overcome boxing.
I know that UFC one was a watershed moment,
but gene labelle did that 30 years previously.
This guy really is a founding father of modern name mixed martial arts.
That's the guy that stepped in and did MMA before there was ever MMA.
He really stood up for us and showed everybody that carried you down,
guy.
You really are someone to be back in Flint.
I can't thank him enough for that because adoptions had fairly effected me so
many years later and now as well.
You're part of history,
sir.
That was amazing,
man.
You're part of the history.
That's fascinating.
I can't believe it.
You know what,
what makes you so sadistic?
You've always had that reputation for being you.
You enjoy like net cranks and
uh,
it's the,
ed teachers I've had being a sadistic and uh,
like
it doesn't matter how the game is played,
it's the final score.
And I think they say that with these sudden they should say,
I'm nice.
I'm good looking.
I am a technician,
not a [inaudible] bastard.
Ah,
that's terrible.
But you say yourself,
well,
the,
you know,
because you know,
you have to go to confession.
If you go to church and yes,
a dear God,
I have a sadistic bastard cure me,
cure me,
and they,
you know,
uh,
I'm sure the Lord will do it,
but it takes time.
And,
uh,
I don't know how much time I have left.
When you were going to Japan and you were learning too though from the Japanese
and you're experiencing all that anti American hate when you were learning
Judah,
what was that like?
It's a challenge,
but to me there's,
it's like a small dog,
a big dog,
a cocker Spaniel,
a great day.
And they're all dogs as people.
If we're black,
white,
Chinese,
Hispanic,
we're all people,
we're all equal.
And uh,
so,
uh,
but when I worked with them,
it was like at the end of World War Two there a lot of the,
uh,
my teachers were in man's dinar at camp for a few years and they had
hostilities,
but don't take it out on me.
I,
you know,
and I never paid attention to it.
She did the get over it after a while.
Like they accept you after a while,
you sure.
When I got good enough to beat the hell out of them.
Uh,
but meanwhile I was a cannon fodder.
I,
uh,
they had me for lunch for a year or two.
And then I,
uh,
I worked out seven days a week.
I was only one that worked out six or eight hours a day.
Uh,
and,
uh,
go to different gyms this before and after you had met Karl Gotch,
during,
during the same time,
but call a at Luther says different coaches.
It's a whole new world in judo.
They didn't allow leg locks.
Okay.
And Carl was great at leg locks.
Luther says was great at our inbox,
arm locks and neck locks at back locks.
And Luther says,
was like a boxer.
Uh,
Karl gotch was like a slugger.
And you learn,
I can't learn everything.
I take the things that work for me.
I eliminate the forms had,
I don't think people should eliminate the forums because a lot of people can't
compete because their body or they're not coordinated enough.
So they do the forums and they exercise to me.
You're wasting your time if you don't spar.
You know.
That's why I say,
um,
if somebody got our judge or referee,
they should have the background of being in the ring or on the mat.
Okay.
And learn it all and they have to have something.
Oh yeah.
But he's so many times like I,
there was a recent fight I want to mention or reference name,
but there was a situation where a guy was setting up an arm triangle.
He had the head and arm choke.
He had it locked in.
He was pinning it down and he was moving to try to get out of half guard and
they were stood up and I started going crazy.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
The guy got like three quarters of the way there to the arm triangle.
He got to the toughest spot,
which is isolating that arm with your head trapping,
trapping the arm and head together and he's getting out of the half guard and
you're standing him up.
That means you don't know shit.
Like you shouldn't be refereeing a fight if that's your,
your move.
I could not agree with you more.
And a lot of times I feel like jumping in the ring and when this guy had the
Hematoma,
I went to the head commissioner.
I said,
they just stopped the fight before there's a permanent injury.
And uh,
you know,
I have learned though,
keep your mouth shot.
Uh,
our,
uh,
people want to sue you.
They want to fire you.
Yet when you still say like you just said the guy he's doing a triangle,
he could have choked him.
Armbar them.
Uh,
yeah,
I get upset at too.
I get upset when they,
uh,
they make people stand up.
I think that's silly.
I think,
I know that people want it to be exciting,
but my opinion and this,
I think this is very valid.
There's parts of MMA that are not going to be as exciting as people want them to
be.
People love of a slug out,
you know,
chocolate Dell style fight.
They love a Stephan Bonner Forrest Griffin style fight.
But there's real validity to a guy being able to take you down and hold you in
position.
It's,
it should be up to you to get out from under there.
And if you can't get out from under there,
I don't agree that a referee should be able to come over and stand you guys up
and artificially create this situation where you're striking now just because
the,
the guy,
the guy can get up,
he gets up.
If he can't get up,
the guys on top wins.
I mean,
it's,
it's really simple.
If a guy can hold you down and punch you in the face,
even if it's boring,
he's still holding you down and punch you in the face.
That's realistic.
It's reality.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I mean you're,
the thing I admire about you and there's very few things,
uh,
but you've been there,
you've done that.
And you know,
if a guy's screwing up a judge or a referee,
and like he said,
he made him stand.
A lot of times the referee is compelled by the audience as Saturday.
He says his fighter or the people that are cheering through four,
they're there on the ground,
they can't get up and they'll,
they all get up,
stand up.
And the referee,
I've seen it a million times,
will stand the guy up,
sending them both up and uh,
no reason for it.
And it's the rules.
I mean,
it's in the rules of the referee can do that and they do get encouraged to do
that by promoters and commissions and the like,
people want to see a stand.
They don't want to see a fight that gets really boring and you can make a fight
more exciting with a good referee.
But my point is,
mixed martial arts is supposed to be realistic outside of I gouges and groin
kicks.
What can we do to make it more realistic?
Well,
one thing we could do is don't have artificial standups.
If a guy like Ben Aspirin,
like Ben Aspirin is a guy who gets tossed around a lot lately and um,
I think there,
there's rumors that he's going to sign somewhere else,
but Bella toward let them go in the UFC didn't pick them up.
That's one of the best grapplers in the world.
He takes talented strikers,
takes them down at will and hammer fists him in the face as long as he wants to.
And even though he has been stopping a lot of guys,
just the fact he's able to do that over and over and over and over and over.
He's winning against high level competition too.
Dangerous strikers rag dolls and take some down,
gets on top of them leg rides,
them,
hammer fists,
him in the face.
Hey,
maybe he's not knocking anybody out,
but I don't see anybody stopping that either.
That's a realistic technique.
Well,
uh,
you know,
I think the fans should learn a little bit more about Brazilian Jujitsu.
I how to get a iron bar,
a neck lock.
Well,
even wrestling and control the way aspirin is
able to control guys on the ground.
Not Impressive.
That's impressive technique.
No,
they'll get a crouching Nelson and they'll crank the guy like pitting his
shoulders.
But I personally like I want to see somebody hurt or be in a position where they
have to give up and yell uncle where you get a guy in a back lock or an
abdominal stretch or a a heel hook or a knee bar.
I want to see that.
I it cause that's action to be along with the,
you know,
the standing,
you see guys throw punches.
Uh,
but you see a lot of steady guys,
they run away the cause so they don't get hurt.
Did they come in and throw a few punches and kicks then back off again?
What was it like for you to see the UFC erupt when 1993 when it first came
around and it was like real primitive,
like much more,
much closer to what you engaged in in 1963.
Uh,
I loved it.
You know,
I'm a fan.
A lot of people say,
ah,
it's just a fad.
It just a fad.
It's too late.
I say that anymore.
It out draws professional boxing and wrestling together.
MMA does.
And uh,
uh,
I owe that all to Dana White.
No doubt him.
And the fatigue was,
well,
the big thing is,
the big thing about those guys is they're really fans and to,
to have people who are really fans of mixed martial arts being in charge of the
biggest mixed martial arts organization that's so important.
So key.
Those guys love fights.
They love him.
I mean,
I talk,
I've called Dana Up,
I'll call him up at one o'clock in the morning.
We'll talk about fights for three hours.
We just go on and on it.
What about this?
Oh man,
it's got,
I'm telling you,
man,
we'll just have these crazy fights about,
and you got to remember he's coming off of this loss.
And you know,
those,
those conversations you don't have with someone who doesn't really love the
sport.
And it's one of the reasons why they're so good at promoting it.
They fucking love it.
Well,
if they'd love it,
it makes,
uh,
makes me happy now.
Just not all the for the money.
How happy are you that the women's MMA is being dominated by a judo woman?
It isn't a judo woman,
just,
it's a person that I've loved forever,
since she was a baby.
Wow.
Uh,
she couldn't speak until
she was six,
you know,
she had heard about the bear local courts around her neck and now she would as
stop.
And I think,
I think it's classic.
I love her as an individual,
love his mother as an individual.
And to me,
she's the best a woman that I've ever seen it mixed martial arts.
What about Cyborg?
Cyborg is very,
very,
very good.
And probably the second best fighter in the world today.
Uh,
next to she's fucking
dangerous.
Oh yeah,
she is.
But uh,
she has weaknesses.
Oh,
they all do.
Everybody's human.
Everybody has has weaknesses.
You Go,
the thing about Cyborg is,
in my opinion,
if you go back to the Gina Carano fight,
there's like Gina Carano.
I had moments where she was controlling her on the ground,
but,
and people say,
oh,
well,
you know,
Gina Carano controller on the ground,
but cyborgs Jujitsu game was a lot better than that.
Now cyborg is one like some serious tournament as a brown belt.
And she's,
I've seen videos of her grappling throwing men around.
She's scary and she is dangerous.
Very,
very good,
very good strike anything.
But she's a lot heavier that Rhonda and Rhonda does it need to go into,
uh,
the 105 she can make one 35 and this cheek can't,
I mean,
and you know,
the thought is the smart money would be that they'll probably going to have to
fight one day,
uh,
after they're both over the hill.
But by over the hill,
I mean,
I think once women's MMA starts getting the respect that it deserves.
And I think this first episode,
the first season rather when the ultimate fighter with women kind of proved that
because I think five fights on the main card or three out of five fights were
women.
You know,
they're,
they're having more fights with women.
Now it's becoming a,
a point where some UFC is,
have two women fights at a 10 or 11,
and it's pretty interesting.
And I think that as women's MMA grows,
there's going to be some,
we're going to need some new new blood and new challenges.
And New,
really scary individuals knew like clubber Lang's for women and she's the
clubber Lang for women.
You know,
Cyborg is,
she's the Mr t in the background,
you know,
put your food,
she's there,
the angry hungry fighter waiting to get in.
It's just dangerous striker.
I,
she's dangerous and a lot of the people that she went against,
she outclassed.
Yeah.
It was at a different class.
Yup.
She went in and gets a lot out of the people that weren't that good.
Well,
they're not that.
She's so strong for a woman.
She's so strong.
I've seen her lift up a certain people,
Ben,
uh,
that had a short arm scissors on him and she had physically,
she's strong,
ridiculously strong and she cuts wait to get to one 45.
So she's walking around one 60 whatever and,
and big as a house and,
and has hammers.
She,
she's a very dangerous striker.
Well,
the whole thing is,
it's nice to be a dangerous striker,
but the bottom line is,
is she going to make it easy money?
Right.
Well,
that's my point was that like if these guys were going to really keep building
the way they're building,
I feel like it's one of those inevitable fights like Marlos Koonin you know who
she is,
caught her in Invicta and Cyborg smashed her in the last fight.
It was,
it was really shocking.
I was like,
wow,
like this one,
she's getting better.
You know,
she's really physically strong and she's getting better.
I think one day they're going to have to see that.
But there's all a lot of talk too because cyborg tested positive for some male
hormones or what have you.
Some some sort of steroids and there's a lot of talk that
when you do something like that,
when you take some performance enhancing drugs,
it's been recent studies on it that show that some of the effects are actually
permanent.
Some of the enhancing effects that they don't go away.
Well,
I don't know that for sure if you say so.
I don't know either.
I'm not just talking shit,
uncle gene.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I always do.
Uh,
it's to me,
I know the lion was ada used to play football and he died of,
you know,
uh,
steroids.
Well,
I don't know what he's got to have brain something in.
And the steroids evidently went to the brainy.
I can talk to about work the movie with him.
And he said that,
how am I going to compete when this guy had crossed the lines on a juice yet?
Oh,
uh,
so to compete they have to do it,
but gosh darn you're putting your body on the line.
He was only 43 when he died.
Um,
there's a lot of people back then apparently also that we're taking human growth
hormone that was coming out of cadavers and uh,
they were catching diseases from that,
allegedly.
Did I just read that online or did someone tell me?
And they could have been totally full of shit.
Disregard that until you Google search.
It lays laser gentleman,
but he died fairly young.
43 years old is a very young time to die from a
brain cancer.
Yeah.
He was enormous at one point in time to talk about was huge.
And very talented.
My point was,
you can't bring up Cyborg and not be,
she could because she's so physically strong.
He can't not mention the fact that she tested positive for something.
You know,
you can't because there's always,
it's always the allegation.
When you look at her,
you're seeing pictures of her,
you see,
pull up a picture of sight.
Was this,
this her grappling with Tito Ortiz?
How ridiculous.
I think this is the show,
uh,
where uh,
she,
uh,
picks up up,
that run.
Yeah.
They're working in the gym and uh,
he had her down and she physically picked up up.
She's hot,
strongest Shit,
man.
For a woman.
That's ridiculous.
I mean,
obviously their training,
Tito's helping her here.
Yeah.
But at Tito's,
a 200 plus 200 plus and a wicked grappler.
Yeah.
Good guy.
But pull up a picture of her like Cyborg muscular.
He could see how ridiculous she's strong.
She was like back when she was beating Gina.
Carano.
Alright.
But I don't know.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know what,
how much is natural and how much of is it is enhanced chemically how much,
how much was,
but whatever it is,
the package has left is a pretty damn impressive.
She's scary for a woman.
I think she's one of the most dangerous women
planet.
Oh,
uh,
you know,
if she ever went against Rhonda and catch weights or whatever,
it'd be the biggest,
uh,
show in the world,
especially if Rhonda continues to keep winning the wishes winning,
and she's got a tough
fight coming up against me.
Should take,
that's going to be interesting.
It should take,
it is a very,
very good,
good,
uh,
fighter.
Very talented.
In fact,
I didn't know you probably got a Christmas card and part of it was a design
that,
uh,
don't let the enemy get behind Ya.
You have all these crazy patches.
Every year I bake out like 20 of these at my house.
Oh yeah.
Don't let the enemy get behind,
you know,
bull.
And he's got a,
you got,
this wasn't here.
What does this one,
uh,
Rhonda,
the American beauty Roundhill wow.
Brian's going to t he's gonna tape that to his underwear from no.
And I said,
oh,
can I watch his underwear and shit or why?
I think this is your favorite tape.
Right.
A patch there.
If he could get a picture of it,
when in doubt choked them out yet.
That's my favorite.
And uh,
uh,
that's good.
But I tell Ya,
do you have one of these solid cold,
uh,
cauliflower ears?
Solid gold,
Well,
I call it solid gold.
It's made of a brass,
uh,
Jay.
It's not magnetic cater,
but it's a cauliflower ear and a,
some a replica of your ear.
Yeah.
And he has a lovely four.
I had a them operated on.
It almost can be work as it work.
As an earring.
Huh?
Would be a pretty ironic if you were a cauliflower ear as an earring on like
each side
you had yours operated on.
Well,
what I did not
beauty,
uh,
cause have just a natural good looking guy.
Um,
I had allergies and,
uh,
the doctor says,
well,
I'll take the cartridge out of your ear and put it in your nose so you can
breathe.
And that was about 20 years ago and I haven't been able to breathe since.
Yeah.
The deviated septum operations.
Well,
hey,
it's a,
he said it was the turbinates.
Yeah.
And uh,
evidently it wasn't,
it wasn't,
uh,
another words the operation did.
That's a common thing with those nose operations.
If you don't go to the right doctor or,
and you know,
if it doesn't work out well,
I made a mistake.
I went to,
uh,
always for all your fans,
I'd say get a second and third opinion and the operation is the last thing you,
uh,
consider.
Yeah,
well,
there's a lot of people that have gone through,
um,
the wrong doctors or,
or it didn't work with them for whatever reason.
But for me it was a life changer,
boy.
And getting,
getting my nose opened up.
I think most boys,
by the time you reach a certain amount of,
uh,
age 25 years old,
you've been hitting the nose.
It kanga times.
And a lot of times when you've been hitting the nose,
there's probably been some,
some bleeding inside there and you get sort of the same effect that you get in
your ears with cauliflower ears.
He can get that in your nose,
swollen tissue and cranked up.
And that's why a lot of fighters,
they talk with a very nasally till like may hand Miller.
I was always telling him to get his nose fixed cause he had like this,
you know,
he would talk to you and you could hear the,
the fact that his nose was clogged up.
A lot of fighters have that vendor lay had to get his,
uh,
his nose operated on.
They took a piece of his rib cartilage and they use that to,
yeah,
these deck to construct a new nose and he got a big one this time,
like nice and full.
So I couldn't really breathe out of it.
Oh,
that's good.
If he can.
Uh,
I've had a few and those operations in the,
with top doctors supposedly,
and they said nothing we could do about it.
Wow.
That's when doctor messed it up.
Understand what the cauliflower ear,
it bleeds into the side.
And if you don't drain it within a day or two,
it hardens up and turns into cartilage.
Is that,
is it Cartlidge?
Is that what it is now?
You can feel both.
Certain parts of my here,
it's a hard as a rock.
It's a white weird shit that grows and salad.
It's,
it's in.
If you fell right here,
the inside of my ear,
um,
it's hard.
I mean,
you can use squeeze it.
It's just hard.
You're Randy couture used to stick ton of people's heads.
Like when he would take them down,
you know,
he has his,
it looks like he has a mouse living in his ear and he would take guys down and
get that ear on their face,
grind them down with it if it,
if it had hurt him and hurt him.
No,
it was a,
it was like a rock on his head.
He had a rock thrown out of his head.
Well,
he has big ears.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
in the old pro wrestlers they'd ever dread there.
That was,
uh,
an honor to have a cauliflower ear badge of courage.
I always wore a head gear,
like a pussy that see you're smart.
I like hearing things.
I liked my ears work in the way they're supposed to work.
And I've talked to a lot of guys that have like serious cauliflower ear and
they've been pretty adamant about it.
Like you're hearing changes,
like you don't hear it like,
like while eat Ishmael,
his,
you've seen his,
they're like literally cauliflower.
Like he's got cauliflower grown out of his head.
Oh Man.
And your whole so tiny now too,
you know.
Uh,
actually when I had on the one side,
the year was a little too swollen and when I laid down on the bed and a hard
service without the pillow,
I could feel it.
It sorta was very uncomfortable.
But,
uh,
now I don't know the difference.
What a weird side effects of grappling the cauliflower ear.
Yeah.
But at least w we were talking about earlier about damage.
At least a grappling damage is pretty obvious.
Like your knees start going or your back is bothering you,
you got issues,
you kind of know what it is.
The real issue with MMA that is that the hidden issue is the,
the impact,
the strikes,
taking shots and how dangerous it is.
And I'm really glad that you're,
uh,
adamant about that.
I'm really glad that you make a big deal about that cause he'd been around
there,
you've
been around the fight game for a long time.
You know what's important and uh,
you,
you speak out about it and I think that's really important.
The only initial investment Joe you have in life is your body.
If you don't take care of it,
nobody else will.
I mean,
if something's wrong with you,
I can't say,
hey,
something's wrong with you.
I know if something's wrong with me,
I'll go to a doctor.
Uh,
he's a witch doctor,
but I'm not prejudice.
You understand,
you go to a doctor and uh,
he takes a care of you and then you know it.
Don't let it linger.
If you have a bad knee,
stay off it.
Rest is the best
or get it fixed.
Especially guys who try to fight without ACLC and they just don't want to go
through the Rehab.
Like get it fixed,
man.
You got to get it fixed.
Cause you'll chew the inside of your knee up while you're a while.
You're,
you know,
we're trying to rehab it.
And if thinking eventually going to get surgery,
you're going to do irreversible damage to the inside of your knee.
If it's unstable.
Ah,
well you gotta get a,
he,
he old and a lot of people just don't want to get it healed.
My wife used to kick me in the butt for years and now she's got a bad knee.
I says,
go get a cortisone shot.
May God be bites,
judge.
I can't talk her into it.
She will not get a cortisone shot.
I says,
well,
you got to have the whole need cut off.
All not got to do it.
So,
uh,
another words,
I'm teasing naturally,
but a while she does have bad wheels,
uh,
you know,
but it didn't really come from kicking you in the ass.
Well,
she missed a couple of times because I used to go down the stairs pretty fast,
you know?
But uh,
you gotta take care of it.
They only initial and ventured and you have in life.
I repeat this over and over at your body.
Take care of it.
You,
I love the fact that you say,
get that fixed.
Get it fixed.
They can do it now.
They can fix a lot of things.
Yeah.
There's a lot of surgeries they can do.
If you can afford it,
get effects.
If you can't afford it,
don't fight.
Get it fixed before your fight.
Don't.
I know,
I know a bunch of guys who fought without ACLC and I'm like,
you're crazy.
They just tried to teach her knee up and go out there.
I'm like,
you're going to be unstable.
And it's,
it's a scary enough proposition to fight anyway to fight that compromise where
you can't move.
You can't move you up that leg.
Well,
it's going to give out and buckle on you.
That's one of your most important assets.
Your ability.
Yes.
It's got to get worse.
The ability to decide where you're going to be in a fight.
The ability to decide whether you're gonna be moving in or moving outside aside.
That's very important.
If you can't do that,
you can't defend yourself properly.
And guys like they get real short sighted when it comes to,
oh,
I need the money.
Like you also need all your chips.
You're going to give away a lot of chips if you get knocked out because you've
got a bad wheel that's get it fixed.
Yeah.
Get everything fixed.
What do you think about,
this is the thing that we have to deal with today that didn't exist back in your
day,
but testosterone replacement therapy for athletes.
You know,
you're seeing a lot of that where they're,
they're talking about testosterone replacement for men who are in their
thirties,
twenties even.
I mean,
guys in their twenties have applied for it before and it's a very strange thing.
You're,
you're seeing all these young men that have testosterone issues and they're
getting this artificial testosterone injected into their body,
which a lot of people feel like it's an unfair advantage.
Uh,
it depends what you use it for,
for competition or just a walk around better.
I have no problem with him.
In fact,
I use it myself.
I use testosterone myself to walk around better,
but I'm not competing against anybody.
I just,
I go to a doctor,
I get my test levels measured and I keep them on the low side of like a healthy
male.
But I'm not competing.
And I think when,
when you're fighting,
I think either no one should be able to do it or everyone should be able to do
it.
I think it gets real squirrely when you start like giving young men the ability
to add testosterone to their system allegedly because they had some sort of a
medical condition.
If you really did have a medical condition.
Okay.
I feel for you and I understand your desire to compete and it would certainly
help you if you had an artificial testosterone or you know,
uh,
x whatever exogenous put into your system.
But if your guy is abusing the system,
it seems easy to do.
All you would have to do is take a bunch of testosterone and then get off it.
Your levels are crash.
Then you go in and get tested,
they test your levels being low and then the lady said,
well,
I need some testosterone.
And then you get on it and now you have a ridiculous amount of recovery ability
because you're,
you have the hyper,
hyper natural levels of testosterone in your system and you're regulating it
yourself with injections as opposed to nature regulating it by making sure that
you're healthy with nutrients and what have you.
When you say a injection,
injecting it yourself under doctor's supervision,
are you?
No,
they injected themselves where you were put cream on cream is the most common.
You take a testosterone cream and you rub it on yourself.
That's the most common.
Or the,
you know,
there's a gel.
There's cream is actually,
they make a spray now you can,
uh,
Lyposomal you can put drops under your,
under your tongue and it gives you a testosterone.
The end of the problem with those is they get abused because guys do them and
then they cycle that you,
it only lasts,
like with,
with the oral ones,
it's only stays in your system for about 24 hours.
So you're,
your levels will spike,
but then if you get tested 26,
27 hours later,
it's not even in your system anymore.
You're,
your has already gotten rid of it and you're back down to a normal level.
Whereas that whole 24 hour period before that,
your body's recovering at a very rapid pace and it gets out of your system in
and out very quickly.
You're supposed to take it every 24 hours,
but if you don't take it for a day or two,
you'll test like you,
you're a normal,
healthy person,
then you get out of there and then you take a bunch more.
So it gets real weird cause guys can,
if they know when they're going to get tested,
then they can kind of plan it.
Well,
if you have 24 hours to get rid of it yet.
Oh yeah.
And,
uh,
I,
I don't care that much if it helps you out,
go for it.
A go car.
One of the schools I teach at,
uh,
he went down to Mexico to get these shots and his leg and everybody laughed
about it,
but it was really bad and it cured it.
W what did he ever wrong with his leg?
The knee.
I'll get an injury.
And so what were the shots that he got?
You know,
it was like stem cells or something like that.
One of those things I've heard,
I've heard people doing that before in other countries,
but boss route and actually just got back from something like that.
His neck.
Yeah,
he's had some serious issues.
I sent him to the guy,
um,
who's,
uh,
doing Regena keen,
that blood spinning stuff they're doing in Germany.
There was a guy who was doing that in Santa Monica that I actually had done on
my neck and it was amazing.
I sent boss down there to see if that could help him as well.
Well,
how long ago did you send it?
he,
I don't know if he's gone there yet,
but I know he was just gotten back from whatever he had done in another country
and he was saying it did miracles.
Like he's saying he's training again.
He feels great.
Like his body's starting to rebuild itself,
like whatever it did,
like you said,
pretty quick after the procedure,
he started feeling fantastic.
I love Bossy is amazing guy.
Yeah,
he's a little sick,
but he's bike kind of people,
you know?
Don't,
you kind of have to be able to just talk a little bit sick to be really good.
Uh,
different is a better word.
It's different.
Dignified.
Yes.
There we go.
Uh,
you name a champion in any sport and
you get to know him and that they're a little different.
They're driven in a different special boy.
Yeah,
yeah.
In anything basketball,
track and field,
whatever it is.
If there's somebody at the top of the heap,
that guy's got a quirk.
That guy's got to be a little bit weird.
He's going to be a little bit different.
Uh,
according to your standards,
like there's a basketball player.
I had met one time,
he's nothing but jelly beans.
He eats nothing but jelly beans.
Well that's part of his diet of jelly beans.
And uh,
I seem to live with it,
but
well,
you know that strong man,
God has been fighting in MMA now.
Would it put Yanoski do you know who he is?
He was a winner of a strong man competition.
It was like huge,
enormous guy.
Well,
he started fighting,
MMA fought Tim Silvia got beat up,
but uh,
he's,
he's beat some guys too.
He,
so he's a big strong guy,
very dangerous,
eats a lot of candy.
It's candy all day.
And he said,
uh,
well I think what he's saying is that his lift,
he does so much lifting and his lifting,
it was so intense that he needs sugar all the time.
And he was getting a sugar in the form of candy bars.
And a lot of people are like,
wow,
that's crazy.
Like that sounds so stupid.
But look,
the bottom line is
the guys world,
strong man champion,
obviously he knows what he's doing.
Uh,
yeah,
but how long is he going to live?
I worked at a show with Arnold Schwarzenegger,
and there's a guy in there at jeep Swenson.
He was,
uh,
he chewed up every half hour,
and I know that name,
cheap Swenson.
He,
uh,
played,
in one of the Arnold shows.
He pulls me through a wall and a is strong man,
but a nicest,
sweetest guy.
But he had a,
he had 26 in charms.
Nobody has 26 inch arms,
and they were ripped and he had so many things in the future and it went to his
heart and he killed them at as a,
as a young man.
He said he was taking it every half an hour,
every half hour.
He said,
excuse me,
but not a,
you know,
he just go in and give myself a shot.
So he was just completely off the rails.
Yeah.
But who knows what is practical and what is over the,
is that him?
Yeah.
Wow.
Could be,
that's a large man.
Well,
you can't tell.
She's not on.
How old was he when he passed?
How old was he when he died?
Does it say?
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
Look at the size of that dude now God like that is very strong,
but you know it's short lived,
can only work for about 30 seconds and then it's got too much muscle to feed.
Uh,
they're trying to teach a guy that was the world's strongest man name Anderson.
He remains 40 for me many years ago and he had a,
he,
they wanted to make,
I'm a pro wrestler.
After 30 seconds,
he's out of gas and he trained for a different
quick boom boom.
They're just trying to get big and,
and strong.
But I train for the wind,
wind cardio.
If a car is out of gas,
it don't run.
Nhler Christopher Cross song.
I like to win.
Yeah,
that's important.
That's a call.
God's thing as well.
Like he was a big stickler on,
on a conditioning type.
Hundred die body weight squats a,
is that true?
Did you have to do there before every training session?
That was the warmup.
500 body weight squats for folks who don't know how crazy that is.
That's so God damn hard to do.
And talk about about,
uh,
an hour or two with just,
just bodyweight warming up.
Show a lot of stretching exercises too.
I mean a lot of stretching exercises.
Well he was very aware of what benefit of the body.
He's a very,
very,
uh,
very well schooled
guy when it came to like techniques of training and one of the reasons why I
endorsed things like the Mace Ball,
you know,
that he understood that doing difficult movements like kettlebells who's a big
proponent of kettlebells and along those lines that those full body movements
are the ones that translate directly to grappling,
uh,
at other sports too.
Yeah.
Uh,
I know when I was doing the,
all those kettlebells stuff and unbelievable how strong I was picking up things.
If I grabbed the guy's wrist,
I had him,
you know,
and uh,
they don't seem to do that anymore.
Well,
those are making a comeback.
Those things are actually becoming a really pretty popular lately.
Kettle bells of,
um,
made a big comeback over the last like 10,
15 years.
And a lot of people are training with them.
Like there was always these photos of a fade or in Russia has a bunch of kettle
bells around him.
But although that I heard at towards the end of fate or his career that he
really didn't do much strength and conditioning,
he just did only fight training.
Uh,
I'll put it this way.
He was getting,
he was one of the best of all types.
I can't take it no doubt.
But he fought too long.
You think so?
Oh,
of course.
The last few fights card,
what?
It flew by Dan Henderson and yeah.
Yeah.
I made it his last two or three fights.
What happened to him?
Perdome beat him.
I mean he fought a few times in Russia on his own and did well.
You know,
he fought,
knocked out Pedro,
his own,
um,
fought hustler hustley fight.
Did he fight Jeff Monson over there as well?
I believe he did and he fought quite a few times,
you know,
but yeah,
I think he was certainly,
he was out the door.
He mean you can only keep up that level.
The level that he hadn't pride,
like when he's beating Minataro and when he beat Zulu and all those guys,
like he was incredible.
I mean,
it was,
he was so good.
He was good on the ground as could everywhere.
Sambo is hit.
Yeah.
From a left field.
He swung from left field.
I says,
God,
I good boxes should be able to Bob and weave and get out of that way.
He's so dangerous.
Oh yeah.
Unbelievable
fight.
I mean,
he basically,
I'll kickbox cro cop,
but he definitely took him down and beat him up on the ground a bit.
But the,
the majority of that fight was spent on the feet with him walking down,
Cro,
cop.
Uh,
that's it.
But when you're just over the hill,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
uh,
you still have enough ability to beat the average guy and you get your
confidence back by beating a Jib boney.
Then you go to the top guy and you've got to [inaudible]
it hurt.
Yeah.
No,
you're,
you're absolutely correct.
And,
you know,
as you said,
there's a time to get out,
you know,
and uh,
I mean I'm glad he's,
he decided to stay retired.
Um,
I'm glad you know,
he had a few fights pop man.
I would've loved to seen him in the UFC when he was his prime and
they were making an offer to have him versus Brock Lesnar.
Ooh.
That would have been crazy.
That would have been maybe one of the greatest fights of all time are the
biggest fight rather of all time.
A Brock Lesnar that great a grappa he had the best.
Okay.
Tackles take downs.
That's all he had.
Uh,
that bad.
Anything he could take anybody down and he'd be a great football player,
a Lineman,
defensive lineman.
But in
Brock he had a lot of publicity.
Okay.
If he's stuck around a little bit more and he had sicknesses and finishing
holes,
he'd be a
champion for a long time,
I believe.
I think so too.
I think,
well,
first of all,
the stomach issue,
so a big one.
I mean they removed 12 inches of his colon and then you know,
he fought,
I think it was like a year later.
It wasn't very much longer than a year if it was,
and that's just a long,
that's a long time to be off the game and not a long time.
When you have an injury like that to heal up,
when you're getting kicked and need in the body by a guy like Alistair Overeem,
I mean that just seems like a terrible idea.
And I think that if you are going to do a guy like that correctly,
like if you were the engineer of a Brock Lesnar,
you go,
okay,
here I have a thoroughbred.
I mean this is a stud.
You have a giant athlete who can walk on his hands.
He's an Ncaa Division one heavyweight champion wrestler APP.
Well we need to do here is do this the right way and they should have brought
him along slow.
They should have brought them to smaller organizations,
worked on his kickboxing,
had him in there with guys that he could beat and,
and build the hype up.
It kept,
but he was,
he jumped into the deepest end of the deep pool quicker than anybody ever second
MMA fight ever.
He's fighting frank fucking mirror in Vegas.
It wasn't a Vegas,
I think it was in Vegas and gets leg locked.
I mean that's a big leap to go one MMA fight in next MMA fight your fight and
Frank Mir.
That's craziness.
Yeah.
Well it did.
Did he beat him?
Beat him the second time.
Second time,
smashed him the second time was frightening.
When you saw a massive improvement.
He got up in a Lake Lac right away.
Yes.
He got him in the leg lock pretty quickly in the five but a lot of the reasons
why it got him in the leg lock is because the referee told him he was hitting in
the bay.
I think it was hitting in the back of the head.
They did something where they stopped the exchange and then they restarted the
exchange where he was hammering on Frank Mir and then they broke it up and then
they re engaged it and mirror to is to crafty.
It was too crafty on the ground back then and then caught him.
I mean,
I'm not sure if I'm absolutely correct about that.
I think I am,
but I'm,
I could be incorrect,
but I know that,
uh,
that the referee stopped it way too late.
He got caught in that knee.
Bonnie tapped and tapped again and they tapped again and the referee finally got
in there.
And it's that kind of shit that we were talking about.
Like the referee has to be danced to protect a guy.
And when he see a guy getting tapped out
with a leg lock,
the moment he does this,
the next one,
it might be too late.
Like you gotta be right there on that first one happens,
snap those ligaments it out.
Yeah.
I mean,
you've seen it.
How many times?
1,000.
1 million.
How many guys have you seen get their knees exploded,
uh,
more than,
you would expect I,
for years and years,
uh,
needlessly,
Ya know,
right.
Needlessly and guys kept back into the gym too soon.
And,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
you gotta take care of the,
uh,
your body.
That's everything.
And people pass it off,
you know,
so with,
uh,
a guy like Karl Gotch,
I never saw him get hurt.
Guys that hit him or something.
It's like hitting the,
the table.
But he paid the price to when he got older.
I mean,
didn't he have a hip replacement?
So I believe he did that from that,
you know,
over a period of years and not relaxing and resting.
If you're injured,
you're a you a cat.
He fees that he,
uh,
later on in his life I talked to him and his wife passed away and that,
I think that made him go down hill.
And the only thing he had in his life,
he said,
what's a good cigar?
And a cat from the neighborhood used to come over every day at night at five
o'clock,
he'd feed the cat and then he'd take off and he said,
he,
the cat never learned to say thank you.
You know,
uh,
that was his main source of company towards the end.
And he got a lot of invites to be with,
uh,
the wrestlers and he didn't want to be,
he says,
look up my body now.
I'm not there anymore,
you know.
And so he didn't want even be around it.
No,
he didn't want to be around it.
And it would make me cry to think there is a god and you know,
he should be put on a pedestal.
A man like that.
Cause he taught a lot of guys.
Uh,
he went to Japan and taught soccer.
Robert Ryan.
Yeah.
A lot of those guys are,
they became good shooters.
Yeah.
A lot of guys learned a lot of techniques at the Brazilian Jiu Jitsu guys
weren't aware of as well.
Did a lot of sneaky shit that guys didn't see coming.
And it was a lot of it was Karl gotch.
Yeah.
A lot of it.
Karl gotch.
Yeah.
I'd love the fact that there's different schools of attack when it comes to,
uh,
to martial arts submissions especially,
I mean in the striking as well.
But I love that there's the judo attacks and then there's the Jujitsu attacks.
The catch wrestling attacks and as far as like,
you know,
stand up.
Like I love the fact that you get a guy like Leo Machida who has a totally
different attack.
He's using a karate style attack or so many fighters are opting for a more,
more Moitai centered.
No.
Well,
what I think of mode tie vote,
I think of elbows and knees and a little bit different stance.
Learn it all,
learn it all.
Add,
learn what is effective for you.
I learn knees and elbows because the old wrestlers they used to like grab her
around the head,
jerk it down right into the d into it.
You have there goes your opponent's teeth or is those or very much into the
solar factors.
Once you hit it in the solar plexus,
the guy's down and out.
So
do it and make it seem like they were just grappling,
but they're really slamming you into their knee.
Oh yeah.
They uh,
uh,
they busted the stirred them.
Uh,
you know,
I think it's a great move.
It might not be as spectacular,
but anytime you hear bones scratch and the guy's willing on the ground in pain,
it's sort of a,
it's nice.
It's a sexual thing for me.
You a fan of the Schultz brothers guys had that very aggressive wrestling style
as well.
Yeah,
but one of them's dead down.
Yeah.
Unfortunately,
I think,
I believe they're making a movie about that.
Are they?
Yeah,
I believe they are.
So the dupont guy was some freak who used to
Russell,
uh,
with the,
what do you call it?
The war machine.
Uh,
try to run everybody over with his tank.
Yeah.
He was apparently completely crazy,
but he liked to,
uh,
he liked to Russell
and he had money and a Lotta history,
uh,
with different people.
Like I say,
everybody or you say,
I say everybody has their own quirks or personality.
Brian pull up,
um,
pull up Mark Schultz disqualification and you could watch him use a double wrist
lock.
He actually used the Camorra to take this guy down and a,
it was in the 1984 Olympics and he hit the Camorra and just yanked the guy's arm
part.
Just smashed him.
You shouldn't have said that.
I just wet my pants.
Oh God.
It's a beautiful move.
And Schultz at the time,
Schultz did a little bit of competing in MMA as well and the early days the UFC.
But I think what happened was they threatened him to a,
that we're going to remove him as a wrestling coach if he continued.
This was during the dark ages of the UFC.
He fought Gary Goodrich and Gary Good.
Richard was still wearing a Geeky,
so that tells you like how long ago this was.
And Schultes just dominated them just with pure wrestling.
He was an animal
not wearing any pants either.
I say,
ah,
that's mark.
I'm warming up.
He's getting ready.
If you to um,
you could see the,
the,
the hold at one 15 go to a one 15.
They show how he was a disqualified.
He gets a hold of this dude in the double wrist lock position.
And this is like a classic in MMA now.
Lucky hits this and he's got the leg in between and just smashes his arm apart.
I mean that is absolute perfect technique in MMA.
But a,
in wrestling they weren't having it.
Look at the,
the technique here,
Emmy drops down perfectly.
It just mangles that dude's arm.
I mean it was a beautiful way to take a guy down.
It's a beautiful technique
but illegal and that sport.
Yeah.
Well the pro,
the good shooters,
uh,
that's what they do.
That's a standard technique,
right?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I think it's great.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you go,
when you look at the old catch wrestling,
like farmer Burns' books,
which shows all the different positions that he was practicing and you see like
a lot of those are being used in MMA today.
The lockdown,
the half guard,
that was old school catch wrestling technique,
you know,
even saw triangles.
I didn't know that they had triangles.
Oh yeah.
At triangle chokes.
Absolutely.
But they were sort of more refined by the Brazilian Jujitsu guys,
right?
Yeah.
The A,
you can't knock that.
They approved down it because there wasn't that many people that were really
experts.
Is it real exciting for you now to see all these people today?
Like d so many grappling tournaments.
Grapplers quest,
Naga regional championships,
Brazilian Jujitsu and submission,
wrestling championships all over the place.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's,
it's amazing.
Uh,
what is amazing to me how these people now wrestling's back in the Olympics.
Yeah.
Thank,
thank whoever.
Zeus,
I got a kick out of the Russians.
It says,
what are the crazy?
Then he used a couple of your vocabulary and he says,
those people don't realize that's the oldest sport in the world is Greco Roman
wrestling.
It's also one of the sports.
It's the most character building sport known to man.
It's one of the most difficult sports at the highest level to compete at.
You can't get by just on talent.
You have to work hard.
There's no way around it.
No one rides for free.
And the guys who work harder are going to be the guys that got you out.
And when you,
they're going to beat you,
they're gonna figure out a way around your,
your,
your defense and they're going to push you just a little bit harder than you
want to be pushed and they're going to get you down,
they're going to beat you.
And that's the difference between champions and run her ups and that sport.
It's work,
work and will,
and it's a,
it's a like a hugely important part of the,
the character of young men that go through that.
It,
it shows them what they're capable of,
shows them that they can overcome some seemingly insurmountable barriers.
Absolutely.
It's,
um,
again,
back to what you call the
cupbearer,
which is a double wrist lock,
uh,
when it show's over with,
have I ever showed Ya how Carl got you?
Did it,
what was the variation in the car got stuck?
Yeah.
You'd be planning on putting me into submission once you show me on Brian,
you could tap him.
I will.
You'll be glad I've heard.
I've heard nevertheless,
allow you to put someone into a position.
Oh No,
no.
Nice to have a guy like Brian.
Brian,
you're so gummy,
you won't even get hurt.
He said it's a sexual thing,
but not for you.
Yeah,
believe me,
you won't even get a wet.
You know it
like they do the cupbearer there and they grabbed the risks.
Are you going to let them do it too?
Oh,
you're crazy.
Okay.
What does he have to do?
Oh,
I don't believe bullet.
Please be nice to him.
He's very delicate.
Don't hurt him.
Okay.
The Camorra like that.
Yeah.
We're not going to do this hard.
This is what you do to put the pain on.
Okay.
Now here's the difference.
I grower here.
Now tell me what it is.
Oh,
you're doing a wrist lock as well.
I see.
Wow.
The tap too
outrageous.
So you're,
what you're doing is you're attacking the wrist as well.
Is that what it is?
See here I turn it and instead of going like this,
it's just straight up.
Oh,
I see.
Okay,
so you just,
you have his hand twisted around and he's got no strength to get out of that.
That way your hands all twisted up like that.
Very hard to get any strength.
Right.
I won't do it.
He's going to do it.
Shit.
He could put his hand between my legs and roll me back,
but see that way you get the,
don't let him see you doing that.
It's going to hurt you
here.
I'm not going to do it.
Okay.
He's going to do it.
Go
going like this.
You know,
you're just go up.
Is it harder to hold onto it that way?
It seems like,
especially with a sweaty hand might be a little difficult,
but good family may,
right?
If you could get your thumb inside the glove and they don't catch you
on the glove.
It depends how big your hand is.
Karl gotch had a big hand and very small woman hands.
Yeah.
Brian is a very small woman.
Hands.
You can let go of him.
Gene,
you're making me uncomfortable.
I feel like you're gonna hurt my little buddy.
Get out of there.
Brian,
quick.
You just wrestling with a crocodile.
You fuck awesome.
Did it felt scary?
Do it tight?
No,
no,
no.
That was that.
No,
I could see where you could just,
no reason to be a bully.
And that's what makes you feel good.
Jean.
Um,
when you,
uh,
when you look at the state,
grab that microphone,
sir.
Pull that towards you if you would hear.
Oh yeah.
That thing.
Round pear shape tolerance.
When you look at a MMA today,
what do you see like the biggest area for growth?
What do you see?
Like when you see like the technique of fighters,
what's one thing that you would like to see guys
improve on?
What would I like to see him do?
Get more variety,
more versatile and they're attacking me.
Uh,
there's some,
uh,
things that are not used that I think are good finishing holds a,
they don't catapult off the turn buckle or the cage.
They don't
pulled off the kids.
Like Anthony Pettis does like that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
I mean you're,
you're there.
Lean back,
shoved the guy out and he comes back.
Then he's away.
You can do something.
Uh,
the cage doesn't have nearly as much give as ropes,
right.
Ropes out.
It's a little easier to do,
right?
Yeah,
it's easy.
You can kind of manipulate it a little and push guys by Moitai guys are great at
that.
The trips push guys off the rope and,
and trip them as they're doing it.
Yeah,
but in mood tie if the trip,
um,
it doesn't count.
I mean you could throw a person down and mood tie and they just say a stand,
well actually in real moy time when they fight in Thailand and actually counts
for a lot.
I mean the stuff they have in America,
like k one you mean?
Yeah.
Well that's one of the biggest arguments against k one is that they don't use
the full range of techniques and glory as well,
which I'm a big fan of.
I love that high level k one style kickboxing and I loved the tournament style
like Gloria is doing,
but really I'm a real boy.
Ty has elbows as well,
like standing elbows and I love it.
I think those elbows are very important and the ability to grab the back of the
head very important.
And when they,
when they cut that out and say you can only grab the back of the head for like a
couple of seconds,
you taken away a lot of the fight.
That's a lot of the fight is that the pummeling and the trips and in,
in Muay Thai,
in Thailand,
those,
that's big.
That's very important.
The grappling is very important that being able to control the infighting and
the throwing each other down,
they'll slams mean something in,
in Thailand and
yeah.
Well everywhere you go,
they have different rules for the same sport in the Olympic,
uh,
knocked down is like a good hook or a jab.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
It's crazy isn't it?
And a guy could get knocked down three times and win the bout yet.
Oh yeah.
It's ridiculous.
They count how many times you touch a guy in the face.
Well,
it'd be better if,
uh,
they had international rules that were same.
Same.
Well,
I think they've kind of changed the,
the style of Olympic boxing judging now,
right?
It's not,
it's not that that's straight forward just touching a guy.
I think they do count for damage.
Now I might be wrong though,
but it certainly varies between that and the way they judge professional boxer.
Well I only pay attention to that once every four years.
Professional boxing or the things I used to with guys that
were going to the Olympics and I think uh,
the United States had better competitors then.
I don't think it's a challenge.
They should have MMA in the Olympics.
I believe.
I believe MMA is very pure and very popular sport.
And if it was in the Olympics,
boy I think there would be a lot of attention on it.
And I see these be some incredible fights.
The only thing that I liked better than MMA is synchronized swimming in the
Olympics.
Well it's more aggressive.
Uh,
you know,
you're fighting through water all the time.
Yeah,
that's true.
But the movement is a fight.
If they have sports like that and I don't knock them,
why wouldn't they have that man may it says popular.
Yeah.
I think they think,
you know,
maybe at this point in time it just hasn't been accepted enough in the public.
I mean if they were thinking about taking wrestling out,
just showing that look how clueless that ideas and it's just ridiculous.
Well,
it depends what you're looking at.
When I look at the sports in the Olympics,
they don't show everything that I want to say.
They do show a lot of swimming and track and field,
which is good.
Two of my favorite things,
but uh,
the judo is very,
very sparse coverage.
Yeah.
Add boxing very sparse.
Yeah,
you're right.
And Taekwondo,
same thing.
Very hard to find a taekwondo match when the Olympics on television,
unless you're in Korea,
I'm sure South Korea,
they probably covered the shit out of taekwondo,
but I'm in America,
I think.
Um,
I think what you're seeing also is a lack of boxing talent from the United
States in a weird way that we haven't seen in a long time.
You're not seeing nearly as many gold medalists.
He remembered the days of like mark Breely and Meldrick Taylor,
those got pronounced Whitaker and they're all gold medal,
gold medal,
gold medal.
They were just dominating the Olympics.
Tyrrell bigs dominating the Olympics.
Yes.
And you don't really see that as much from the American boxers.
It's kind of unfortunate,
you know,
I think boxing is gone down the drain.
Uh,
and I mean at the Olympic Auditorium,
which my family had for 38 years,
every week was a boxing show.
Then they were back seeing shows back east every week.
And now where the boxing show to,
uh,
you have a big boxing show,
it's two guys that fight once every two years to build up something.
If they don't have all the heroes,
there's definitely less boxing.
But you know what,
at the highest levels of the game,
I think Floyd Mayweather is the best boxer that's ever lived as far as like pure
boxing talent.
I think the guys almost untouchable.
He said,
I think he's the most best defensive boxer and the best use of like the
controlling what happens inside the boxing ring.
It's incredible boxer.
Okay.
Let me ask you,
I knew he was okay.
I agree with you.
I love that Guy Biting Sugar Ray Robinson.
No,
no,
no.
The wave others there different kinds of
the guys we're talking about money.
How much does he make?
He makes them all set of anybody ever.
Okay.
How come the MMA guys aren't making that kind of money?
Well,
he gets Munster paper view numbers.
The numbers that he gets on paper view,
if they're coming to their,
first of all they're coming there to see Floyd Mayweather jr him period.
And the numbers of paper you,
he broke the world record.
He got like 2.2 million in his last fight and maybe even more.
Might have been 2.4 million when he fought Canelo Alvarez and just shout them
out.
It's his production money team productions,
you know,
he's in charge of everything.
He also,
I'm sure has to pay for everything.
I mean I'm sure there's,
he's got a lot of costs involved in promoting these fights and whoever he's
doing it with,
whether it's a Bob Arum are,
you know,
de la Jolla there.
Everyone's making a lot of money.
It's an insane amount of money you're getting from this guy.
The UFC is a different world and the guys who draw big on paper view,
they make a lot of money.
And like George Saint Pierre makes a lot of money and I don't know what that
number is,
but I know he said it's between four and $5 million per fight.
He also has a lot of sponsors,
big names,
sponsors,
you know,
the,
the champions at the top level make a lot.
But the difference between how many paper views he gets,
like maybe 500 thousands,
a really good one for George Saint Pierre,
maybe more 600,000 Floyd gets 2.2 million.
I mean that's,
those are bananas numbers.
And he's the only guy that does that.
Him and Pacquiao,
he's the big guy obviously because he's the best marketer.
He,
and he's marketed himself that everybody hates him.
I mean,
it's really a genius.
Pro Wrestling move.
I mean,
you've got to appreciate that he's playing the heel.
I love it.
And same thing with Rhonda,
who I love,
uh,
you say playing the heel.
Uh,
Rhonda says where it's at.
You know,
Rhonda plays for keeps,
you know,
she's,
she's not trying to make friends.
She's not trying to win any publicity events.
She's not trying to,
you know,
do PR and get everybody to love her.
She wants to break me.
She takes arm.
That's what she wants to do.
And she's pretty,
pretty,
pretty adamant about it.
Meisha Tate's a great competitor and everything.
But
if I was be should Tate,
I wouldn't show up that night.
Wow.
You,
but you can't tell what's going to happen but never tell.
Well,
you know she had Ron is back and the first fight.
Oh yeah.
Well Rhonda had to a couple of people that have had her back because she's got
so much confidence.
Uh,
and she's so strong confidence that she can,
she can get out of everything and anything.
Um,
there's a picture of you guys together.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't that I was a picture of somebody behind a,
that's a picture of Ronda.
Yup.
There she is with you.
I didn't know if they can picture.
Yeah,
zero is perfect.
My arm feels cold.
When you broken
judo gene,
the bell broker,
you should be honored.
One of men.
And can you autograph it here?
A lot of graph your cash.
Don't let anybody get behind you.
Yeah.
You don't ever have let people do that again.
Hi
Jim.
What more can we say?
This was a lot of fun,
man.
I really enjoyed it.
Really enjoyed talking to you.
And I'm in your book too,
right?
Hold on one second.
Hold on a second.
Day of Sabbath May.
If I never see the back of my neck again.
I,
I've done a lot of textbooks.
So what?
But I do a book just for gene labelle and the few very intimate friends.
Okay.
Now this is one of my very greatest teachers.
I learned this from
judo,
Joe Rogan.
Oh my screwed.
Uh,
Kennedy Kennedy get that he had,
and this is like a leg,
a trip when someone takes and grab it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I,
why did I have to be the technique where you get your boobies grabbed?
Uh,
hey,
it works for me.
I feel terrible about this at an inside leg hook,
grapevine,
the color,
uh,
Occi Gary and,
Japanese,
uh,
judo.
So it's an inside grape vine,
and then a punch to the face as I would it is there.
Oh,
I only read the first page,
the second page too devastating.
Oh,
it goes to the balls to,
oh,
well let's see.
And then it guys,
can you get to the balls?
Yeah,
you could see the balls there right there.
Oh yeah,
that's wonderful.
And then the inside leg trip and then a punch.
Love it.
Well,
I'm honored.
I'm honored to be in your books or it means the world to me.
Uh,
and uh,
congratulations on being really the first mixed martial arts fighter ever on TV
here in America and,
uh,
graduations on your 50th anniversary of that.
And uh,
just thanks for being an awesome guy and thanks for,
uh,
you know,
sharing so many great stories with us.
And I,
uh,
I'm,
I'm honored to be your friend,
sir.
Uh,
I consider it a privilege if I never see the back of my neck again.
Joe Rogan is,
uh,
a friend of mine.
Uh,
you want me to go sign an autograph stuff there?
Oh yeah,
I know Joe Rogan.
Gene the bell.
You're a real original love.
You love you too,
brother.
Thank you very much everybody for tuning into the podcast and thanks for
Squarespace for sponsoring it.
Go to squarespace.com and use the offer code Joe and the number 12 to save
yourself 10% off.
And thanks also to lumosity.com I gotta read the copy here cause I make sure I
say it right,
lumosity.com which is essentially a website to train your brain,
a gym for your brain.
Go to lumosity.com forward slash Joe,
that's lumosity.com
forward slash Joe Click the start training button.
Start playing your first game.
Thanks also to onnit.com it's o,
n n I t,
the the big sale that we have ends tonight.
Uh,
if you're hearing this on Monday,
December 2nd ends tonight at midnight Pacific Time,
you can save a shitload of money at,
on at.com.
If you hear this after that,
use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Lots more fun this week.
Um,
what do you got going on?
Oh,
it's San Jose.
December 11th.
We're having a dirty show at the San Jose Improv.
Me,
Brody Stevens and Sam Tripoli.
Oh,
show.
Pretty Steven show.
It's on comedy central.
Check it out,
folks.
All right.
We love you.
We'll see you soon.
Big Kiss.
Okay.